dude i'm the british women's deadlift
record hold still if you google uk
women's deadlift record my name still
pops right up i hate the concept of
white privilege why because it's racist
it's not real i've had people trying to
convince me i'm oppressed and i'm like
what are you talking about entertain
it's not very clear to me as well like
why he got taken off all these things no
dude i spoke to him the day that it
happened do you know the policy that
they banned him under no was the
dangerous individuals or organizations
when you encourage this censorship or
safe spaces or whatever and you're
discouraging conversation and debate
then it furthers the problem we keep
looking for political realm solutions to
spiritual realm problems and being
surprised when it doesn't work all right
guys bang bang zooby's here i think this
is your third or fourth time on the show
uh in person and i thought a fantastic
place to start would be the importance
of not being a coward on the internet
today
it feels like there's tons of people who
publicly
don't say [ __ ]
and then i go to dinner with them i talk
to them in private and they'll just
go off
and i'm like yo
you're like a little [ __ ]
and you're super based or like at least
willing to like say what you actually
believe
in private like why is that happening
oh man that's that's a big question and
i think last time i was here i talked
about the pandemic of cowardice that i
felt was going on in society and
happening across the world
and
it's something that i
i understand it's not a new thing it's
not a new thing um i think one of the
most common human desires is to
fit in with people
and another is to avoid criticism and
backlash and avoid rocking the boat i
think there's a lot of reasons why we
have those tendencies and it makes sense
right most of us don't want to go around
every day and deal with more conflict
than we have to both online and offline
so
you know there's no one and it wouldn't
be sensible to be constantly
saying absolutely everything that's on
your mind at all times or getting in
every single conflict or argument that
you have to and so on so i understand
that to a degree
i think the problem is when it does
become
actual cowardice right not just like a
basic level of decorum or sensibility
but when people are genuinely
afraid to say something that needs to be
said or do something that needs to be
done
and i think especially over the past i
mean the past few years that we've just
lived through
it became so clear
number one how pervasive that cowardice
is and how unwilling people are to speak
out even when it's very very necessary i
mean you've really seen this play out a
lot over the past decade to be honest
with you
um
but i i think most of it is is
self-preservation and wanting to
maintain social status and social
currency and to you know of course
there's people who have people often use
their jobs and their families and say oh
well you know the truth is we all have
stuff to lose people have this idea that
oh there's these people who can speak
out and these people who can't because
these people are in some amazing it's
like no there's people who are broke
with jobs who will speak out and there
are people who are
billionaires and who are self-employed
and have true fu money and whatever but
they're absolute cowards in fact this
goes for the majority of um
celebrities
so
it's more of a character thing i think
it's really a character thing and it's
one of those things that day to day it's
not always a problem but
everything we do is habitual
so both cowardice and
courage are both habitual and contagious
so that's why i use that term pandemic
of cowardice right because when everyone
else is behaving
in a certain way
the fewer people who are speaking out
the harder it is
to speak out and one of the things that
frustrates me about it is number one it
it's why certain things keep getting
worse because people are not taking any
type of stand and continually refuse to
for years on end
um
but also it puts the burden on it
increases the burden on those of us who
are willing to say something right
people want to hide behind the sofa and
tirano imagine i don't know you're
you're with a group of friends and i
don't know somebody jumps you and your
friends all jump and hide behind us over
and they're like yeah go get them palm
go get them it's like bro like you're
hiding behind the sofa like you coming
don't put it now now i'm you know
there's five of us and five of them now
it's five on me
and when the fight's over then you have
a friend who's like yeah yeah yeah
yeah i'm glad they left
hold me back yeah
exactly exactly so that's why it can get
it can get frustrating so to me
one of the things i hear most often i
mean i've been i travel a lot i've been
to probably i mean most most people were
not traveling much over the last few
years i went to eight different
countries dozens of different cities and
when i get recognized in public or if i
do meetups or you know the thing most
people say is well firstly thanks
people who recognize me um
but
i'm often thanked for my courage
and
that's really interesting to me because
on one hand it is a compliment and i'm
like thanks on another hand it kind of
annoys me
because it makes me realize like why is
the bar for courage so low like i don't
consider myself maybe i'm a more
courageous person than average but i
don't consider myself like
ultra brave i mean there's people who
are
in in the military there's firefighters
there's police officers risking their
lives dealing with really dangerous
criminals and so on i'm like man i
wouldn't want to be in the military
right like i'm just i'm just talking i'm
saying things i'm talking on podcasts
i'm talking in my music i'm talking on
twitter
that to me that's
i mean if people don't feel free to talk
here in the in the usa in the uk and
canada and australia or places where
you're supposed to have actual
freedom of speech both in a legal sense
and also in a cultural sense then what
hope do we have for the rest of the
world and
part of the problem another part of the
problem with it is you can't fix
anything unless you can talk
this is one of the biggest issues i have
with political correctness and when i
talk about political correctness i'm not
talking about basic politeness and
civility um i'm talking about political
correctness in the true sense that
there's things you you all you you can't
talk about you can't oh you can't say
that
it's like what how how can there be a
fact or a piece of data or a statistic
or something that's just real or even
even if it's an opinion that you're you
just can't
you you can't say because if you can't
if you're not allowed to discuss a topic
you can't you can't fix it
and that's the one of the biggest
problems that is going on and is
plaguing the west as far as i'm
concerned there are certain issues
that are happening on different levels
societal issues crime issues cultural
issues political issues and
you're not even allowed to talk about
them well i mean you are like i'm not
saying you're not allowed to but people
feel like you're not allowed to do it
pressure it's like legally you're
allowed to talk about it and if you talk
about it uh no one is gonna come knock
on your door and say uh you are under
arrest yes but
you will
lose friends you will be shunned from
certain groups and you will feel the
social pressure of why are you talking
about that why are you questioning this
thing
but do you think that there's been a
shift from i don't know maybe it's
nostalgia maybe it's a
hindsight bias maybe it's just uh we're
young dumb kids but growing up it felt
like when you were told something
by
a position of power expertise influence
government you know whatever you want to
put in that category
the default was you believed it until
you found something to make you question
it yeah
now it feels like the default when we're
told something maybe it's the internet
maybe it's whatever the default is i do
not believe that and i question it and i
only believe it once i learn the
information
that confirms that it's true
do you feel that shift from like the
default position being acceptance to now
maybe questioning that doesn't mean you
don't believe it as much as it's just
like the default is now critical
thinking or critical questioning of what
you're being told have we lived through
the same past three years
i don't know have we it's not the
default you don't think so no the
default is complete acceptance of the
narrative clearly i don't know if i
agree with how can you disagree after
what we've just lived here because
if you look at uh
the virus as one thing i agree okay
if you look at the economic story
i don't think the majority of people in
america believe that uh inflation is low
not a problem transitory whatever well
at this at this point it's hitting them
in the face
yeah so it's hard for people to deny it
now a year ago even though you could it
was obviously coming a year ago i think
majority of people would have bought
that line now you you can't say it and
have any credibility because people are
there and they're in their store or the
grocery store when they're at the gas
pump and they're like well this is
like like that [ __ ] says five dollars
and never said that before exactly
exactly right so
and this this is this is the sad reality
is that people humans always have to
learn the hard way
right not every single person but in
general people like learning the hard
way uh they want to put their hand in in
the fire and get burr you can tell them
yo don't touch the fire the fire is hot
and this goes across a lot of different
subjects but oftentimes the lesson will
not be learned until it until it happens
then it affects that individual directly
this is something i've talked about for
many years and one reason why i publicly
started speaking out more about a lot of
stuff
was just that i could see
where you could i could i just i have a
good foresight i have good foresight i
practice second third fourth order
thinking and it's like okay well this
thing's gonna lead to this thing and
this thing's gonna lead to this thing
and if there's no
resistance
one crazy thing that can happen in a
population is a very tiny minority of
people who are dedicated
can completely shift and control society
and culture right and i'm not even just
talking about the people who are
referred to as the elites or whatever
i'm talking about fringe activist groups
i'm talking have you ever heard of the
esg movement yes
yeah
yeah but but even even on a lower scale
right there are some really kooky ideas
that have been floating around at this
point for years
which almost nobody believes in
but
people are afraid to say that they don't
people will still go along with the
narrative or at is there an example of
something that like sticks out your mind
dude i'm i'm the british women's
deadlift record holder
still
say that again for people so they get it
right i said i'm the british women's
deadlift record holder
bro
no woman's beat you how can they they
need to have some advantage um
they need to have something most women
do you still are the record holder uh i
think if you google uk women's deadlift
records someone can verify this for me
but i think my name still pops right up
um but my point is i did that in
february 2019. this is three and a half
years ago now this is still a
conversation this is still a quote
unquote debate and so on bro
no one
believes this
nobody how how many people if you go
outside you go in any in around the usa
even and you ask people
are biological males and females
different do you think it is fair for
males to compete against females in
profession
no one believes it no one believes that
men can get pregnant no one believes
that women have penises but
we're living in this weird world where
people would even be afraid to say what
i just said oh my gosh she just said
that women don't have penises it's like
bro
like
we know this that's not a controversial
statement why am i why am i even saying
this like we're in this weird battle of
of for reality that's one of the most
concerning things about about this all
is that
it's not that okay we're agreeing on
objective reality and people have
different
opinions
on
how to interpret it or what should be
done with it or so on it's people are no
longer even agreeing on objective
reality we saw this again all through
the
all through the pandemic situation
and it was like well if
if we can't even like agree just on the
the reality and numbers and date you
know just
even just what we can all observe
then we're we're in massive trouble
right this goes back to like i think the
default was always uh at least the
perception it was like science and math
were not political now it's not
completely true and uh maybe the science
standpoint because for
decades centuries whatever uh there
would be certain scientific
breakthroughs people wouldn't believe it
you know the earth is round people get
killed for saying that whatever right so
it's not exactly black and white but i
do think that most people for a very
long time thought that it wasn't like
fox news and msnbc were going to argue
over gravity yes right like like there
were things that were just not
where my mind started to change on this
and i was like oh [ __ ] we're going to a
place we don't want to go
was i read an article this is maybe
two to four years ago so you know i
forget exactly
and it talked about the massive
investment that was being made by msnbc
fox news and cnn in weather
interesting and i was like why are they
all going so hard at weather
and obviously the weather channel in the
united states had been super successful
and and there was a business there
and then towards the end of the article
i started talking about climate change
it's a political issue yes i was like
wait a minute ain't that a science issue
like
what's going on and then that's when it
dawned on me i said oh my god media
companies are going to compete over
science because whoever gets to say we
have the science
gets the political upper hand in all of
their other coverage yeah it dude it's
it's a problem and the politicization of
everything is is a huge problem i mean i
did a threat on this just
the other day on on twitter and i was
just saying this obsession
with
politicizing and racializing everything
especially in the usa it's a big problem
it happens in other places but
not like this like i'm from the i'm from
the uk and it's not
any issue i mean you know i don't know
when this interview comes out but as we
you know just yesterday there's another
shooting that happened
um in a city
and yeah i'm there and everyone's
talking about race and democrats and
republicans and i'm like guys
what the heck man like every time every
time there's a there's a mass shooting
there's a there's a tragedy there's
something awful that happens people some
people's minds immediately jumps to okay
what race was the perpetrator what race
was the uh were the victims um were what
were their leanings were they right
leaning where were they were they white
nationalist or was a white guy was it
was it a black
and i'm like dude like the bodies are
warm
like how how are you immediately some
tragedy happens your immediate thought
is like okay how can i use this to fit
my
political agenda or how can i use this
to demonize the group that i
feel some kind of animosity towards or
whatever and i'm like dude that's sick
like that's that's really messed up um
there's a time and place for certain
conversations but it's just like
man like
and i think even with these with these
situations this is another problem is
that it's all talked about on such a
shallow level
it's all talked about on such a shallow
level you know it's like okay you're
allowed to talk about guns of course you
can talk about guns right you can fish
oh you know it's guns guns guns
you know when can we have the talk about
the spiritual war that's going on
when can we have a conversation about
morality when can we have a conversation
about family and fathers and community
and morality
right when could we even talk about you
know you could you can sort of talk
about
mental health and pharmaceuticals that's
allowed but you know as soon as you go
into kind of any spiritual or moral
realm anything that's a little bit
deeper
you know it's like oh no we we we can't
even we can't even talk about that it's
like well you're going to keep getting
this problem until you're allowed to
talk about it right if you're only if
the thing is just oh we need to ban
ar-15s and we need to reduce the
magazine i'm like bro
like in the uk it's stabbings
and in the uk they do the same thing by
the way they're like oh maybe
yeah we need to we need to reduce the
length of knives i'm like dude if
someone wants to hurt or kill somebody
we all have
access to lethal weapons every single
person we all own knives we all pretty
much own vehicles we have bats we have
clubs we have fists we have feet right
if you want and by the way i think it's
important for people to know that even
in the u.s way more people
are killed by those weapons than they
are by rifles
right more people are stabbed to death
more people are beaten to death
right and way more people are obviously
killed by handguns and so on but it's
just this obsession of you know we've
got this political thing about this
particular
tool
and it's just so it's so shallow and so
superficial and so annoying and
ultimately the reason it the reason it
pisses me off is because
people are just going to keep on getting
hurt and keep on getting dot and keep on
dying until
you until some real conversations are
had yeah right i think a lot about the
media coverage of this stuff as well so
you're talking about like the internet
conversation right to the degree of a
shooting happens and immediately gets
polarized media does the same thing um
yeah but they also uh in some way are uh
by not covering certain things
they are telling us a lot about society
and so uh i don't know maybe the last
couple of weeks or whatever i i saw that
there's a twitter account and uh every
monday uh or sunday night they will
tweet out how many people were shot and
killed in chicago oh boy yeah and
the numbers are like staggering it's
insane right it'll be like you know 35
people were killed over the weekend and
you're like yo what like i didn't hear
about that anywhere else
and then you're like okay go in the
comments take away their guns do this
and then people are like dude the guns
are illegal
but like you can't have the gun right
and the criminal soul somehow figure out
how to get it and it goes back to this
idea of like wait a minute like what if
our entire like framework for evaluating
the problem is wrong it is wrong and
okay so explain it's completely wrong as
i said look
it's a problem of the human heart and
the human spirit
right if you
why why do i think sometimes it's
important to
not just consider why people do things
but to consider why they don't
okay so as we've established we
we both have access
and the physical capability to kill
right we have access to weapons and we
have the capability to kill right
um
why don't we why don't we kill people
no honestly right why well one we want
to be a good person yes right uh two is
uh there's this almost uh social
contract with the people in your
community of uh let's all get along to
some degree uh three is you'll go to
jail right so there's like a punishment
component i'd say that that's pretty low
down
oh yeah
well here's
i think the moral aspects and ethical
aspects are much much higher than the
threat of without a doubt i mean uh i
remember when uh egypt went through uh
the uprising um i don't know maybe eight
years ago or whatever it was uh and it
was like it was twitter it was twitter
it was twitter right and yes social
media without a doubt i think everyone
who looked at that situation and learned
about it would say social media played a
role
but you know what played a bigger role
they didn't have food yes
guess what everyone thinks that they're
a super moral uh ethical person until
literally they're looking at their wife
and their kids and they're like if i
don't go and kill our neighbor
my kids won't eat
and they will die of starvation it's
horrible
it's just it just becomes
the most brutal form of human nature and
obviously those are very extreme cases
they happen
very very infrequently uh globally
thankfully
but you can take the watered-down
version and bring it back to there's a
morality aspect there's a huge morality
aspect okay let's take one let's take
one specific issue which is a hot topic
not just in the us but globally school
shootings
okay
when did that really when did that
become a more regular thing
right it's only in the past couple
decades
for sure the guns have the guns have
been there kids used to work in the 60s
the seven kids were taking rifles to
school kids had guns in their lockers
and so on school shootings were very
very rare right it was around the
columbine time where it started to
become this early 2000s probably yeah i
want to say like late night i want to
say like late 90s or early 2000s and so
on so
how can you
say it's just the guns when the guns
have always been there if the guns have
always been there and the problem just
really started say 25 years ago
right
how can
you know guns were not introduced as a
new thing
um so yes of course there's more guns on
the school campuses twenty-five places
yeah yes this is this this is my point
right or even if you look within cities
like where are shootings happening
what's happening
in places with the heaviest gun control
laws and so on and so forth it's not
just as simple as more guns equals more
shooting
it's it's really not that simple even if
you look at a country like europe i
think switzerland is the most heavily
armed country in europe i believe
followed by finland and you're not
getting a lot of shootings in you know
there's probably more shoot i believe
there's going to be more shootings in
the uk than there are in in switzerland
even per capita and so on so
it's not that simple the problem is
people wanting to hurt and kill other
people
you if you want if you decide if an
individual decides they want to hurt or
kill another person or a group of people
they will use whatever tools are at
their disposal yes sure it might be
easier to kill people with a gun but you
there's bombs there's knives there's
there's vehicles right some of the most
brutal killings that have happened in
europe were just say someone taking a
van or a truck and just running it
through a crowd that's what happened in
new york city right i think it's
happened at least two stories that i
know yeah and in one case they rented
like a u-haul truck
and just drove down the path so the
thing is okay so the questions to me is
like why what what possesses someone to
do that and as i said the flip side okay
most people 99.9 people wouldn't even
dream of doing i wouldn't do it so what
are they getting right and what's going
wrong here and if you look at the
individuals who do this
there's always a pattern first it's
always young men
it's not women doing it it's not girls
it's always young men typically between
say 15 and 30.
okay what else do they have in common
majority of time there's no father in
the picture
okay that's that's a factor often times
they're on some type of psychoactive
substance or
drug right oftentimes they're known to
the
authorities already right there there's
a certain profile where you can narrow
this down
and be like okay what's going on here
right so there's some type of depravity
here there's some type of moral
loss the way this child has been raised
something that's going on in their brain
like there's some there's stuff that's
going on there um
and
i don't have all the answers
my thing is just
this conversation we're having this this
should be the conversation as soon as
people are just there oh you know i'm
talking about magazine sizes and ar-15s
i'm just like dude
you don't think that person could have
done that with a handgun or with a
shotgun or like it's it's just so i know
people have their political pet causes
and they they have their people like
this idea here's another big one and
i've i've tweeted this before and it
went viral i said we keep looking for
political realm solutions to spiritual
realm problems and being surprised when
it doesn't work yeah i think it's a
great way not everything can be solved
with politics and people don't like to
hear that because
in this
rather increasingly secular society
that we're living in
people
increasingly view the government as the
be all and end all and view everything
through this political lens i also think
there's an element where uh when it's
politics
i have a weapon to tell you what to do
yes when it's spiritual i only have a
weapon to try to improve my situation
that there's there's no way for me
really to use uh a spiritual tool
to impact you control you or anything
right yes you can try to get you to go
to church or you know whatever uh
but it's not as direct of a control
mechanism as let's change the rules no
let's use the police let's you know do
whatever i i am i'm reading this book uh
it's called colt uh uh i was in the
bookstore and i saw it now what the hell
is this right opening up ten people and
uh as you can imagine cults have a very
negative connotation um and usually
because they end in some horrific way
yes uh and the first 50 pages of this
book charles manson in the whole story
now charles manson i think a lot of
people would say uh i heard the name
before especially young people uh i know
bad person uh there's some murders but i
don't really know the story
in this book the first 20 25 pages is
all about his childhood okay
it's exactly what you're talking about
absolutely horrific got moved uh
multiple times between all these
different homes in and out of jail uh to
the point where like 10 years old like
stealing a car and like going across
state lines right i mean just like to
the point where you're just like this is
really bad compared to on the scale of
like a bad 10 year old right um and it's
just like
if you looked at that child's life
you wouldn't think that they became the
president of the united states yeah now
you might not jump to the conclusion
that there was murder and colts and you
know kind of the other extreme uh
but it's kind of just like yeah of
course that person has challenges yes
and of course that person probably ended
up in a place
that society was like man we wish that
people didn't go there
and so it just made me think a lot about
like
that is a situation where like
there's no
ability for somebody else to show up
without understanding that backstory and
be able to help that individual like the
context is so important now again that
doesn't excuse the behavior of course do
any of this stuff right it's still
horrific
but like that's a pretty big [ __ ]
detail of a story and as you see some of
these people who go and do these
horrific things today in society that's
what you're talking about like there's
the uh uh the drugs that they're on it's
broken families it's uh
known to the authorities that's the one
that always gets me it's like you're
telling me that the police knew this
person had threatened to go kill people
a bunch of times and somehow they still
they like dismembered a kitten or like
done some really effed up thing
and you know we don't have the data
right so we don't know how many times
does the authorities get alerted to uh
this person is a person of interest
right or however they characterize it
and then what percent of those people
actually go and do something super
horrific you you also can't arrest crime
people for crimes they have not
committed correct right um that's a fact
you know there's there's so many factors
and it and it's complicated you know i'm
not and that's part of the problem i
think this is why people want the simple
yeah you're not losing that you can't
say people people want the simple
solution it's complicated and it's also
generational and it's multifaceted right
i'm not saying that it's just the one
one thing right there can be political
elements social elements uh religious or
spiritual elements like overall
morality and social fabric elements and
so on you know a huge family component
as well um you know how
how rare is it for someone who is like
you know well raised in a stable loving
family to go on and do anything like
this right it's extremely
extremely rare and this is not to say
that you know most people who aren't
raised in that environment go on and do
that but
you know it's um it also begs a question
which i don't have the answer to okay
should the parents be held accountable
for certain actions of their kids
so for example if your kid uh is 10
years old goes to the store uh and
you're with them
and they steal something yes
they may yell at the kid or whatever
they don't take the kid to jail right at
least in the united states
but they held the parents too like hey
what's going on here you know whatever
uh
okay that's like i don't know petty
theft if you even want to characterize
that as a 10 year old taking a candy bar
or something
if your kid goes on and does a school
shooting
okay like that's a whole different ball
game and there's a bunch of stuff in
between
but right now
there's this complex question of
the parents you don't control the kid
yeah right especially the kids over 18
and all these things
but also how do you create a system that
incentivizes good parenting
right and so like maybe it's incentives
it's not punishments maybe it's
punishments and end incentives
i don't know what the answer is but it
just feels like a really important
question that we have to ask ourselves
is like how do we incentivize better
parenting so that maybe we could divert
even it was 10 of the bad stuff yes
that'd be a win yeah and and you know
i'm not a parent yet but it's really hit
me over the last few years that there is
no
i think the importance of parenting is
vastly underestimated and
under-appreciated both in the positive
and the negative okay because if you
really think about like how
stuff ripples out and resonates out
i mean
it's insane so the person i am
and
my four siblings
is yeah some of it is just you know your
genetics and your personal but a lot of
how we were raised
okay and by me being raised in a certain
way and being put on a certain path and
instilled with certain morals
i then have how many people do i impact
on a daily monthly annual basis i reach
millions of people
right and so and those people then also
reach thousands or millions
so the way both the positivity and the
negativity ripples out into wider
society
cannot be understated if you raise a
terror of a child if you raise a demon
child
right
that's not just bad for them and bad for
the fam that's bad for
society that's bad for your wider
community that's bad for your country
because they go on and they hurt people
and they're leaving in their wake this
path of destruction which is now
impacting all these other people and
then oftentimes it becomes a
generational thing and that's passed on
you know you can pass down the goodness
or you can pass on the nightmare um and
yeah sure that that cycle can be broken
in both ways so i think it's actually
understated and under-appreciated just
how important uh parents are and
families are because that's really the
foundation
for
an individual's whole life and then like
i said yeah that individual impacts
others and i think this is uncomfortable
it's very uncomfortable for people to
discuss this like this is a conversation
that's considered very unpolitically
correct right even if you tell people
like it's better for a child to have a
mother and a father
people are like right people want to
immediately want to object to that now
like
not long ago in most parts of the world
as a completely
not not even a slightly controversial
statement it's like duh obviously right
and here it's it's contentious and it's
arg and you know sure if someone's like
oh well you know well i was raised by a
single mom and i'm like bro like no one
is attacking you
people deem everything as an attack
everyone personalizes everything right
when you say it's better for the child
it immediately jumps to
uh don't attack single moms or single
fathers or whatever but it's like
if you're optimized if their soul
optimization is what is the best thing
for a child let's have that conversation
by the way like you can disagree you can
have other facts you like whatever but
it's like stay
focused on what are we optimizing for in
this specific conversation versus try to
twist it around exactly and do you know
another thing that's plaguing the west
is this obsession with exceptions oh
interesting right people trying to base
everything on exceptions rather than the
general rule
okay so
everyone everyone's
we're focusing on exceptions to the
detriments of the norm and the majority
right so with any particular issue
someone will want to say oh well you
know what about this or what about that
and it's like dude can we talk about
like the 90
scenario or the 98 scenario rather than
obsessing over these
um exceptions and basing the rules and
the standards and the norms around
exceptions rather than around norms in
anything you're going to have exceptions
right if i say you know oh people have
uh five you know five fingers on each
hand someone's like oh well you know
what my my auntie has has six fingers on
her well you know oh well what about so
let's make all the gloves right
yeah
that's insensitive you know i lost my
left left hand in a in an accident i'm
like dude i'm not
yes i recognize there are people who do
not have ten fingers there's people with
more there's people with fewer that does
not change the general effects yeah that
people have ten fingers you know so yes
there are children who can be raised in
all sorts of you know there's children
who can be raised in what looks like an
idyllic perfect environment and they go
on and you know they're they're
screw-ups and there can be people who
are raised in very very bad situations
and so on and they go on and achieve
great things yes we we know there are
billions of humans there's so much
variety and variation but objectively
all other things being equal
even by a simple factor of two being
more than one it is better for a child
to have two parents we know this that's
not a controversial statement right and
yes there can and there can be
and you have to you have to acknowledge
exceptions right there are people who
are widows right someone dies or this
happens or that happens right not
everything works out perfectly but just
because not everything works out
perfectly doesn't mean you blow up and
disintegrate the standard
right and this is what i'm seeing i'm
seeing all the standards being
disintegrated right in the name of
making people feel comfortable or feel
more accommodated and so on and so forth
and in this avoidance of avoiding
hurting anyone's feelings in any type of
way we've essentially in the west
prioritize people's feelings over
objective reality even when that's
extremely detrimental you want to see
another great example of this
look at this whole fat acceptance body
positivity thing
right it's it literally is wild it's
wild yeah it's wild right you obesity is
being promoted and
this is the biggest killer of people
this is a problem that again it didn't
really used to be a big problem you
could go back less than 100 years ago
and obesity was very rare obesity was
very rare and just in a century in one
person's lifetime we've gotten to a
stage where the majority of adults in
this country are overweight or obese the
majority
right childhood obesity did not used to
exist right you look at fat kids from
like the 70s or the 80s and it's like
he's only like slightly chubby now it's
like a fat kid weighs more than i do
right and it and it's getting worse and
it got worse over the last couple years
despite the fact that 80 of the people
hospitalized with verona overweight or
obese um you can't talk about that and
it's like dude do you care
do we care about like not offending
anybody or do we care about actually
trying to help people i've always
thought uh for a long time now uh
normalizing offending people
and just like we are not going to be
held captive by
uh trying to tiptoe around offense you
can't do it it's just listen uh again
objectively yes
if you are unhealthy yes it is bad for
you there will be people who hear
you and i say that
and they will be like these guys are
[ __ ] yeah oh but what but what about
someone who had a car crash and has a
thyroid issue and so they got
it's the exception thing and i was like
dude
i recognize most people who are obese
are not obese because they have some
some hereditary
thyroid issue or because they got
disabled in a car accident and these
it's because they eat too much and they
don't move enough yeah but i also think
there's a uh
exception issue
there's also what i'll call like a
reverse extreme issue so when you say
people should be healthy immediately
americans are idiots like everyone you
expect everyone to have a six-pack be
able to fly 400 pounds and they only can
eat like a rabbit
lettuce
you are an [ __ ] yeah right and you're
just like
no dude we're talking about like
can you go outside and walk down the
street without losing your breath yes
right like like that's the baseline to
start yes and then it's even like you
start thinking about uh i do think a lot
about like if you just say healthy
rather than like people should work out
for whatever reason like we're all
stupid you know uh uh idiot animals and
we're like oh healthy sounds like
healthy sounds good like that's a nice
rapper that's acceptable
work out
you shouldn't be able to tell me it'll
work out what are who are you to tell me
that i need to be a certain size to fit
in pants or this or like
no dude just be healthy like literally
just whatever that means for you by the
way
some people feel healthy because they uh
run on a treadmill or ride a stationary
bike or do like cardio stuff other
people feel healthy when they go and
they lift weights some people i don't
know there's a lot of [ __ ] people in
suburban america who if you go around
about 9 30 10 o'clock what do you see
walking a bunch of people walking and
some of them even have some weights in
their hand right like that's how they
feel healthy great
who cares what they're doing it's just
like that direction is way better than
us being like you know what 400 pounds
let's put the mannequin out there and uh
that that that is that's the new
standard yeah that that's like a good
thing look at us we're voting that's
yeah that's that's the worst part of it
it's when they do the you know healthy
at any size you can be obese no you
cannot be obese and healthy right you
cannot be healthy at any size that is a
lie if you are 600 pounds you are not
healthy period right you cannot be
healthy at any size it's a complete lie
and something i've noticed about this is
doctors never say that by the way and
something that's interesting about this
is have you noticed it's only targeted
to women
only there's no body positivity fat
acceptance movement for men
so i i may disagree on that okay and the
only disagreement i would say is the
whole like dab
it didn't work though but but
but
when i go to like a department store
which unfortunately you will not see me
in very often uh but i was recently in
new york and uh they had a bunch of the
women mannequins then
you know whatever uh
and i don't think i saw any of the men
once but i've seen pictures on the
internet of the like dad bod with like
the colored shirt but
have you ever seen that on the cover of
a men's magazine a fitness magazine no
right but you'll see you'll see fat
women
on the cover you know it's um
so this is how you know this stuff is
very engineered
it's very engineered it's not it's not
organic and
people
call it compassion i don't think it's
compassion i think it's cruel
straight up i i think i i don't think
it's compassionate
at all
i think that
man
well you're lying to people that you're
lying yeah this is the part that i think
uh it's kind of like feedback in
business there's a lot of times uh
business leaders and this is pretty well
documented right business leaders would
be super nice to folks and the companies
never work okay because what happens is
like the truth is never said
so you keep going to work every day and
you're never told hey
you're slacking on something we need you
to improve you never improve right and
if you never improve the business
doesn't improve and then therefore it's
much harder to be successful yeah so you
doesn't mean you have to go be an
[ __ ] someone's got to yell and scream
at you and call you an idiot and like
this it's what is how did you describe
it before it's the reverse extreme yeah
that that's that's literally what it is
you say one thing you know i'm like you
know i i i like apples and it's like oh
you hate bananas
[Laughter]
you forgot to mention what about
pineapples what about like it's like
dude like cancelled yeah
that's the thing you know and it's it's
it's just a problem because again you
can't fix
things there are certain things that are
getting worse the obesity problem is
getting worse did you see the adele it's
getting worse oh and people hating on
her for losing weight she lost weight
and all i saw uh two tweets about
nothing i i just gotta keep scrolling
because i'm uh [ __ ] but it's dope
don't come back
it's interesting not to i don't even
wanna make this like a gendered
conversation but don't you think it's
interesting how that's like
like men that's not a male thing at all
jonah hill remember you the actor yeah
he lost a bunch of weight and uh it was
treated very differently of course right
and there's just two anecdotes so yeah
whatever yeah but but it's real by the
way i've observed this my whole life not
just on social media but there is a
difference in this regard right i mean
even if
right what's the criticism of what's the
criticism of of barbie dolls
right that the unrealistic body
standards and this and that or you know
someone there was that in the uk there
was this company called i think they
were called protein world and they had
this ad which said you know are you
beach body ready and had this foot woman
fit woman in a bikini and it became this
like huge outrage thing right they went
after them so hard and whatever by the
way they had a male 1 as well and no one
cared about you know the are you
beachbody ready with the male body but
this one's misogynistic and this and
unrealistic expectations like bro have
you seen have you seen what action
figures look like
have you have you ever seen superman or
batman or wolverine or psycho where
they're bringing pecs in their 11 16
pack and they're like we're just sure
dude you imagine superman with a dad dad
no but but the point is no one ever said
oh this is setting an unrealistic and
harmful expectation for young boys and
it's gonna so there's something like
really interesting going on there right
because women uh
have
through society's kind of reinforcement
more of a focus on
their appearance and i say this as
somebody who uh i've got a
nine-month-old daughter and i think
about
even just if you walk into a toy store
right if you walk into certain things
like you
walk down the street the way that people
say things sure it's like oh she's so
pretty yeah and like i don't have the
experience of having a son so i don't
know would people be like oh he's so
handsome maybe
but like for whatever reason i'm like
no she's [ __ ] a genius you're right
sure like and so it's like a weird thing
do you think that plays into it today's
episode is brought to you by alto i
alright have you wanted to buy bitcoin
or over 200 other cryptocurrencies in
your retirement account well now you can
with alto ira they allow you to buy
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies in a
tax-advantaged way there's no account or
set up fees and it's super simple to get
started you can go today to altoira dot
com
to get started alto ira.com
invest in bitcoin or cryptocurrencies in
your retirement account and get all the
tax advantages while still holding
digital currencies alto ira.com
i think it absolutely plays into it i
think it would be i think it's clear and
obvious that across societies and
cultures that women are
valued more on appearance than men are
women are judged the way men and women
are judged is different and the way men
judge women and the way women judge men
is different right um
i was saying actually to someone the the
other day that uh
you'll often hear feminists in
particular but other people often say
you know that
there's men who look at women like sex
objects
um
there are men who do that sure
um
there are also one could argue that
society and women view men as success
objects
right
um if a man
the way men and women view and sort of
rate and rank each other is is just
different
right it's just different if you are a
high-powered successful
man in your career and you're
accomplished in this and that that
weighs differently to a woman with the
same
achievements right guys will be like
yeah but is she hot
you know that's why i'm surprised
they've never gone off the dating apps
what's that i'm surprised that like the
mob has never gone after the dating apps
where literally uh judgments on humans
are being made by the photo that you're
shown and you're swiping left or right
in like the most uh
impersonal way possible
but the initial impression which by the
way is exactly what happens in real life
too
is based on looks it does and i've
always been shocked that they're not
like this is ridiculous yeah you know
these conversations are interesting
because the truth is
biology always exists
you know so we we can talk about like
this and this and there's many things in
the world where maybe we think it's sort
of
it feels unfair or it feels like a
double standard oh how come it's like
this or you know it should be like that
it should and within reason
you can make certain accommodations
right you can certainly treat people
fairly right this is generally how i
operate across the board and what i
strive to do is simply treat people
fairly treat everybody decently
equal equal is a weird word
because
equal is equal
human beings are we're equal but we're
not right in a in a spiritual sense like
in in a religious sense in a worth of
your life and how the laws should apply
to you and so on i believe human beings
are equal i believe human beings are
created in the image of god right we're
we're all equal
in the literal sense we're not equal at
all
in any way we're all very we're we're
very different we're the most diverse
species that's out there right we're not
equally tall we have different body
weights we look completely different we
have different eye colors some people
are attractive some people are less
attracted some people are highly
athletic some people are very
intelligent some people are dumb some
people are right like we're
we're not we're not equal at all in in
that sense and
also when it comes to say conversations
about men and women
men and women are equal in a sense right
in terms of your worth in terms of your
your value and so on
but we're fundamentally like as groups
we are we're different
and and that's that's not a problem
right there's people who problematize
that right they almost want this like
homogenous
genderless weird society where
it's weird because at the same time
these people will be like diversity
diversity diversity and then at the same
time they kind of want everyone to just
be the same just to be these like
genderless blobs who there's no
difference between the males and the
females and everyone maybe those
categories don't even exist and
everyone's just you know everyone even
earns the same amount of money and
everyone does the same and it's like
dude that sucks like that's and it's
just not real it's not realistic it's
silly to have a goal number one that's
not even a good goal but it's
unachievable it's like why would you
want to achieve that and you're also not
going to you see this in many things
where people are even trying to force
like
certain things to be 50 50 in terms of
gender
right oh we want you know it should be
50 50.
number one is funny because people only
want that in certain jobs and sectors
right i've never seen anyone advocating
that 50 of uh construction workers or
garbage disposal people or crab fishers
or lumberjacks should be female um it's
only like cushy executive jobs and
whatever um
but it's also like why like what problem
are you trying to fix why is it an issue
that most primary school teachers are
female that's not an issue to me men
should be allowed to be primary school
teachers and they shouldn't be
discriminated against like if you're
treating again it comes back to fairness
if you're treating people unfairly
that's a problem if you're unfairly
discriminating against people that's a
problem everyone should have the
opportunity to do what they want but
understanding basic human nature and
basic biology you recognize that you're
not gonna get like this perfect magical
split on everything because men and
women lo and behold have different
interests you're in the bitcoin and
crypto space it's probably what
eight men to one women
not because women women are not allowed
in bitcoin or crypt like it's the most
open is literally like the most open
thing available but there's just more
it's more of a masculine tendency to be
interested
in that kind of stuff right i'm a rapper
what percentage of rappers are male it's
a very male dominated not women are
allowed to rap there's just more men who
are into it and you can find that on the
inverse there's plenty of things that
are female dominated and so on and it's
just like
cool that's fine as long as people are
not being unfairly discriminated against
and there's equality of opportunity at
the point of entry then i don't have a
problem with it let the chips fall
where they do and then people do it with
like race and so on and again they're
very selective with it right imagine how
crazy it would sound if someone came and
said that like the nba and the nfl are
racist against non-black people
right they'd be like oh my gosh black
men are seven percent of the population
and they're over 70 percent of the nba
this is clearly where where are all the
where are the jews where are the asians
where those
it's like the oboe just like it's a it's
america like everyone's allowed to play
basketball well it's also this is how
the nba they discriminated against short
people
how can we forget right like that's
that's unfair yeah right i'm not six
five that's [ __ ] up
michael jordan y'all be talking about
anthony popliano if y'all let me in
there right but like it's like yeah no
[ __ ] there's
you know it's it's really funny how
people do it because when you bring up
those type of examples people see how
silly it is but then they'll run off and
they'll do that in a whole other sector
and i'm like wait why
why would you expect everything
everywhere to perfectly represent the
population demographics that's just
there's a a weird thing of um
when people try to do the right thing
there's people who definitely are uh not
good actors or not kind of
well-intentioned right so put those
people aside
people who say like um let's use a
computer science okay uh uh as a sector
there's a lot of folks who say hey
there's not uh as many women or uh
minorities in that sector now put aside
for a second whether people want to
debate that or not or whatever just hold
that as as a truth yeah
in most cases
what would make sense is cool
let's go do things to incentivize more
of those people to do it yes sometimes
it's like an exposure thing if you live
in an area where no one's ever told you
that's even a possibility then like you
don't know how many kids end up going
through a high school and their high
school had some program they get exposed
to something and that ends up being
their career and if they'd gone to the
high school across town that didn't have
that program they would have never even
been exposed to that thing and whatever
so like okay cool like you can do all
these things that help build up
one group or one effort without tearing
down the others yes and it works in
reverse as well right where uh people
say like um you know the nba it'd be
like saying okay we only can have 50
of a certain type of person whether it's
race tight whatever
so well
why don't you just try to go get more
people to try out that you know fit some
other criteria
and i actually think that if just that
was the focus
cool you identified something that you
want to change like go work to change it
in a positive way but you're not allowed
to tear down other things yes
society would be like way chiller yeah
and people would be like you know what
like i actually like that effort i think
that's great it's when it becomes like a
zero-sum game that's where you get all
the politicalization of it that's where
you get the debates that's where you get
all the [ __ ] sensitivities
and then it just spirals out of
microaggregations yeah because now now
if it's zero sum yep
well we're playing a zero sum game we've
both agreed we're playing a zero-sum
game i'm not losing yeah which means you
have to lose yeah if it's positive sum
then it's much more working together man
i have so many things i could say on
this dude we got a lot long time go
ahead well first first of all this
this zero-sum mindset thing is a real
plague it's a big problem um people need
to understand that life is not a
zero-sum game money is not a zero-sum
game health and fitness is not a
zero-sum game uh relationships and
dating or whatever these things are not
zero-sum
and one of the amazing things about the
world one of the coolest things with all
the diversity we have in humanity is
there are millions of games to play
and you only need to be really good at
one to be successful
right so
i mean just look at jobs in korea like
how many different ways are there to
make money
right so oh you oh you can't make it in
the mba you're not six foot six and
amazing at basketball do you know what
there's another million things that you
can you can create in this day and age
you could even create your own thing
like look at what we both do for a
living like this
we probably struggle to explain this to
like our great grandparents and be like
wait you do what for a living that's not
a job like what do you
what do you mean
well you have a podcast you sit and you
talk to people like wait you you do none
of it none of it no level of it makes
any sense and it's just like
that's awesome so
you don't need to if you're not
competitive in a particular field or
you're just not interested in it it's
like cool like you can
just get in where you fit in man like we
all have a different pool of talents we
all have different experiences and
interests and personalities and that's
dope because
if we didn't if we didn't the world
firstly the world wouldn't even work
because the way everything works with
free trade is we all have different
services and products that we can offer
that other people find value and we're
and we're all constantly exchanging
that's literally what the economy is
people have been brainwashed to think
the economy is like some stock ticker or
something
this was a point i was making back in
2020 when they were locking down and
shutting down and i was like yo you're
crushing the economy but you care more
about the economy than huma i'm like bro
human lives rely on the economy and
human lives are we are the economy
right like our ability to interact and
trade and do all like this is
this is what gives everything everything
value and also gives us meaning and
purpose it's not the stock price when
you say the economy no it's literally
the corner store isn't [ __ ] open and
i need food and if i can't get food you
got 72 hours where people can start
doing [ __ ] up [ __ ] exactly like yeah
and sure they didn't shut down the
grocery stores but they shut down a hell
of a lot of business yeah and and that
was the thing with it so people need to
get out of this zero some mindset thing
this is also where the whole like the
rich thing comes from right people think
that by oh their neighbor made money or
that person has money so therefore they
must have jack they must have stolen it
from everyone else the reason why there
are poor people is because there are
rich people there's people who believe
that there's hundreds of millions of
people who believe that that poor people
are just there because there are rich
people and it's the rich people being
selfish and it's just them being greedy
and that's why you know there's this
limited pool of money and they're just
hoarding it so those people there can't
get some and
i mean people have believed this for
centuries it's what
so much of like marxist thought and what
it's all this zero-sum mentality
thinking so people need to get out of
that mindset and everything because it's
number one it's literally not correct
and then number two is it just makes
people very resentful and it creates
more animosity and more division and so
on and it stops people from taking that
personal responsibility and bettering
themselves coming back to a different
point that you were making before
i'm i'm so glad you you talked about
this um
[Music]
encouraging people to know about and
have access to certain opportunities
because i experienced this myself in a
very interesting way when i was in
university
so um i studied computer science at
oxford
when i was at office
for going to oxford man are you from
cambridge or something um
you're educated oh you have an unfair
advantage
you know what people at oxford and
cambridge call the other university the
other place oh jesus christ so people
from cambridge call oxford the other
place people from oxford pokemon is the
other place
there's a little a little rivalry there
um
but yeah when i was in university
it was really interesting so in my first
year there so in the whole university of
i think i think oxford at the time i
want to say has around i want to say 12
12 to 15 000 undergraduate students okay
um
oxford got put in the spotlight because
out of that say 15 000 undergraduate
students do you how many black people
they had
actually have a guess
i'm gonna under guest now 250. 55.
wow 55 out of over 10 000. wow and so
there were all there were newspaper
articles and stuff
oxford is racist
clearly this institutional racism
and there was all this stuff you know
because that's how people look at things
they just see a disparity and their
brain immediately jumps to some type of
bigotry discrimination racism sexism
whatever it is right they don't
think
and my immediate thought was oh wow
that's low
how many applied
and then if you look at it it was like
oh okay
like not that many people are that many
black people like even applied
and um when i was there i was part of
something called the oxford access
scheme which was to
uh
do exactly what you were saying so bring
in school students
from
certain backgrounds more like it wasn't
real it wasn't like a racial thing per
se but more like a certain inner cities
and state schools and so on places where
most
so oxford and cambridge in the uk are
obviously viewed as these very elite
establishments they're kind of viewed as
things that
there are many people in schools or
certain sectors of life who don't even
think that they or their children or
whatever
can ever go to oxford or cambridge like
it's not it's not even on
their radar right like if you go to if
you go to like a private boarding school
or you know you're from eden or like
there's a whole tradition of people
going to oxford and cambridge right but
from certain schools it's like no one
from that school has ever gone to oxford
or cambridge like even the teachers are
it's not even on the radar the students
don't believe that it is guided in a
different direction if that's even an
aspiration yeah so so this scheme was
just to you know
show people and encourage
academically gifted students regardless
of whether they're from a private school
or state school or whatever um
to consider higher education number one
and if they have the academic chops
potentially oxford or cambridge
and that i think is the right type of
approach so if someone does think oh
okay there's
you know like there's okay there's a
there's a real
disparity here like very very clear like
some maybe something's going on there
then that's the way to handle it the way
to handle it isn't to
reduce
the bar or to create a quota system
where you start bean counting how many
people of we need this many people of
this gender and this many people of uh
these race racial and ethnic groups and
so on because once you do that you're
you the only way you can achieve it
through that method is active
discrimination right so if you're going
to create a quota like you said like you
you joked about with the nba if you said
there's okay there's a 50 hard cap on
you know people over six foot
right
right
then now you have to discriminate
against people yeah in order to
so-called balance it out and again
what
you're you're now creating the problem
right because if your claim is that the
problem is unfair treatment and unfair
discrimination and your idea to remedy
that remedy that is unfair treatment and
unfair discrimination then it's like
well
you you've just created a problem this
isn't hypothetical though this is uh
here in the united states yale yes uh
which is you know the probably
equivalent uh as these schools um was
accused of and i believe was actually
found uh responsible i don't want to say
guilty because i don't know exactly how
kind of it played out uh but they had
introduced uh certain quotas and and uh
criteria in the uh academic application
process uh and i think that they
actually ended up uh having
discriminated against asians
and so you like look at it and you're
like oh there's some someone along the
line was saying exactly what you're
saying and they were like well i'm not
just gonna go say it you know and uh
just move on to the next topic i'm gonna
go bring it to the courts and
there was agreement like yes you cannot
do this or you should not do this uh
which then begs the question of like
well what about all the other schools
that yeah exactly yeah there was a big
scandal with it with harvard as well
discriminating potentially against asian
students and
that's um
it's it's so odd and it's also
it's also bigoted in multiple directions
this is the thing right so i'll tell you
one thing that i would
i'll tell you something i would hate
okay
and i never say this but as a black man
i never i never start a sentence with
that right but
i would hate
to think or feel that i am in my
position or i achieve something simply
because i'm like a diverse i was a
diversity hire like that i got into
oxford because they just needed more
black students not because i'm smart
enough or i did well enough in my exams
but just because they lowered the bar
for me because
i mean that's the hard bigotry of low
expectations
so the thing should never be oh let's
reduce the standard it's like cool like
let's try to get we can try to get more
people from whatever community whatever
demographic
over this bar or encourage people to
apply or whatever it is but i think at
that point of application
whether it's a university position it's
a job whatever
you've got to run with the meritocracy
yeah because otherwise you are
you're creating really bad conditions
and i think i think it's bad for
everyone i think it sucks for i mean an
asian student who has worked hard
who is an individual like asians are not
a group like these are individual human
beings a kid who's worked really hard in
school and done well in his exams and
you're going to make it harder for him
to go to a university
because he's of asian
his because his parents are from korea
or from china or something that is
insane that's that's racism like that's
that's crazy also oh there's a kid who's
uh oh his parents are latino or black or
and oh we're oh
he's might not be as smart as the asian
or the white kid so let's lower the bar
like what are you insane
like it's
it's so backwards to me and that's why i
think it's hilarious how it's called
progressivism because like so much stuff
that they do is backwards um
but yeah no i i i have a real problem
with that and i think it creates so much
resentment it's the same thing i i hate
hate the concept of white privilege
explain hate it why because it's racist
and it's bullcrap
it's not real
right like
it it's it's bad for everybody i don't
see how
i i i we we were raised in like a a
normal time right like
it honestly feels like that yeah like
like during the 90s we were just
i don't know i mean i wasn't i grew up
in saudi arabia i was like yo i had
extremely diverse classes but i was like
just whatever like people are people
treat people as individuals none of my
friends are i ever like focused on like
what skin color people are oh your
parents are from this country or that or
whatever we were all just there and it
was all cool everything was fine and i
think that's how like most of us in our
generation were raised but people are
going back to this sort of like racial
essentialism where you're no longer
looking at people as individuals but
everyone is being made
extraordinarily conscious of what group
that they fit into and then not just
that but you are then assigning whether
virtues or sins to entire groups
right so you're telling
a young white kid
that he is somehow
privileged
or he's an oppressor or he should have
some type of guilt some permanent some
type of permanent guilt something he's
never done because
centuries ago someone who shared his
melanin
content
did some like
on multiple levels it's just insane
and then you're telling oh you're
telling the black kid now that okay
well society as a whole all the
institutions the whole system everything
is set up against you
right you're gonna have to work five
times as hard as your white friends in
order
what
the police by the oh also like you need
to stay away from the police because
they're all racist and they're probably
gonna like shoot you what oh and by the
way you should like feel some type of
way about you're just creating
resentment on all these levels now those
kids are going to school and they're
looking at each other not like oh this
is my friend johnny this is my friend
billy it's like oh well i'm in this
position i have this color he has that
color and so
um i should be treated this way or i
can't say this or we should it i don't
like i don't like any of it it's almost
the again reverse extreme yes uh
skin color doesn't matter to now it's
skin colors
it's a regression right because that
used to be the problem it go back to
1850 right in 1850 usa
i was like skin color is everything like
that we should judge people based on
this you know black people are this and
white people are this and so therefore
this and therefore that and it's like
bro okay we all acknowledge that was a
huge problem and then it's like okay
cool we we generally
fixed it got to a place where you know
ninety percent of plus people
and now you want to reintroduce it again
in the name of you know
wokeness or progressivism and you now
want people again to start to view i've
heard you know these so-called
progressive people saying that you know
it's bad to be colorblind
right or no we must see race we need to
see it we need to talk about it we need
to acknowledge in every conversation
right one of these wookies will come
into this conversation and they'll ins
they'd insert it into this conversation
they'd be there like trying to analyze
the power dynamic between us two and be
like oh well you know he's in this
category and he's in this this is the
women's british
deadly champion i want to be careful and
it's also all the assumptions that come
with it as well right like these it's
operating off such a low resolution
world view right these people have this
world view that like every white person
is like quaffing champagne on their
yacht and has like generations and
generations of inherited wealth and what
like they completely like ignore
the
like the
vast majority of white people
and they also have this idea of like oh
like every black person or every
minority person is like
from i've had bro i've had arguments
with people about whether or not i'm
oppressed
people i've had people trying to
convince me i've had people trying to
convince me i'm oppressed
and i'm like what are you talking about
that's so that's the nice of them right
i'm like
like what are you even talking like
because they'll be because they have all
their like academic theories and
whatever and i'm like bro
my dad is a doctor
like i've never wanted for i'm like i am
privileged right i went to freaking
oxford i went to boarding school like
i'm from a great family my parents have
been married for like 40 something years
um i'm healthy
i was born in the uk
like i've got so many like
because they're like oh but you know
still like you're somehow i'm somehow
still a victim apparently of systemic
therapies and i'm just like bro stop did
you see the viral tweet uh uh the guy
was joking but uh he was like uh
recently visited like a portland coffee
shop and uh uh they're really taking
this seriously they have uh created an
area uh no whites allowed oh my gosh or
whatever dude and he basically and he
basically was like describing
segregation but like doing it from the
like perspective
you know some universities have that now
oh there are real places yeah there's
universities that have that now that
have um
spaces for people of color
um or sp
what do they they have different terms
for them but yeah they brought back
actual
segregation yeah i saw a video also uh i
think it was like a maybe a library or
something um and of course it's on
college campus uh
and there was a guy who's like sitting
at his computer and uh
um
somebody's yelling i don't know what i'm
saying that they were feeling uh
they were feeling unsafe because he was
uh in their presence
and like again you see these videos and
you're just like
literally the guy two minutes ago could
have been yelling and screaming and
threatening people and like doing all
this stuff and then all of a sudden you
just see like this calm scene but if you
just take it at face value and say like
okay there's no uh outlier there's no
you know exception to the rule it's just
like some guy's sitting there with
another one you mean he had the blue
live sticker on his um blue blue lives
matter sticker on his laptop who's the
two the two white guys yes and then
there's the girls and they're they're
like and they're just
going off
on this and i was just thinking of these
situations and i'm like
is this because humans are bored and
i'll give you uh uh context of this so
i've been reading a book and it
describes one section uh 1870 to 1970
and it basically makes the argument like
there was so much human progress that
happened in that time period because of
technology inventions of the automobile
electricity all this stuff uh the
elevator created urban density the
automobile created horizontal speed so
we now can move things faster we had the
steam engine we started going through
all that the industrial revolution like
all these things were happening and it
was just an explosion
but in order to describe how great that
time period was as they explained to you
what life was in the you know 1870s and
before
and basically the takeaway is like that
[ __ ] was hard horrible yeah and some of
the key details are men worked until
they died yep there was no retirement
there's no social security there's no
anything like literally you worked
because the day you stopped working your
family stopped eating and so they worked
in the fields also 75
of americans uh in 1870 were in rural
areas
over 70 percent of all workers
worked in what were categorized as
unpleasant jobs
women inside of the household had
immense responsibilities and physical
labor in terms of carrying flour and
water and all these different things
they had to sew their own clothes they
don't do all this stuff and the homes
were all unconnected they called
unnetworked meaning that they had no gas
electricity you know running water like
any of this stuff
that is a hard life that we are very
fortunate today we don't have to do this
there's technology that does a bunch of
this our homes are all connected like
all these different things the shift
from unpleasant to pleasant jobs is like
basically a 180 so you're saying they
weren't debating about pronouns and
misgendering no they were out in the
[ __ ] field with the mule trying to
make sure that they had food for the
winner
and so like you look at this and you're
like
yo we got it so good
that people are bored
and like you want to know how i know
we're bored go check every person's cell
phone and see the hours spent on
instagram twitter tick tock and youtube
and by the way you can be learning about
educational stuff or you can be doomed
scrolling yes and we all do both
but like
if you spend an hour
on your phone basically just rotting
your brain yeah you got an easy life yes
because anyone who has a hard life
doesn't have that luxury
and so it's like is this the end result
of of basically just being so so free so
uh good in life that we debate this [ __ ]
yeah yeah we're living through an
overcorrection of multiple sorts um do
you know why i talk about this stuff why
it's because of what you it's literally
because of what you just said because i
recognize
how good we have it and how freaking
long
it's taken for things to get here and
i'm like guys don't mess it up
don't mess it up
the conversation we were just having
about you know
um racial harmony
dude look around the world look through
history
people were freaking racist and like
like it was horrible people used to
enslave each other segregate brutalize
each other call each other like just
nasty stuff people used to people's got
lynched bro
like it was the kkk at its peak had over
4 million members the kkk had members
like in people in congress they had
governors they had me like in the kkk
like the gov imagine the governor of the
state being in the kkk like that used to
be okay
like not even a hundred years ago and
that is [ __ ] wild
i'm sorry like that is just such a
[ __ ] insane statistic that's what i
mean so when i hear people say like oh
you know racism is just as bad as it's
always been in fact it's getting worse
i'm like dude what are you talking about
like we can recognize things not being
perfect and we can strive for better
right we all have ways we want society
to improve
but if you are going to discount the
progress that's been made over the past
century two centuries
then it's going to lead to you to this
uh area where you lack perspective and
you like gratitude and when you lack
perspective and you lack gratitude as
you you problematize things you create
problems where they don't exist and if
you're not careful you can make things
worse
right so human nature i don't believe
has fundamentally changed over those
centuries right what has changed the two
advantages that we have as people who
are alive in 2022 the key two big
advantages we have over our grandparents
and great grandparents is number one we
have better stuff
we have more technology we have the
internet we have the opportunity and the
tools to just do cool stuff right we
have new tools and we have knowledge of
the history
so
rather than trying to reinvent the wheel
all the time we can look back and go how
do we know segregation is a bad idea how
do we know that racial segregation is a
bad idea right oh because we can look at
apartheid you can look at jim crow you
can look at how this has happened in
different places you can see what it led
to you can see man that was like a moral
deficiency it led to this problem it led
to that problem it was you know and it
was just wrong right you can look back
how do we know that slavery is wrong oh
because it was tried for thousands of
years across different countries and
yeah like we you don't even need to
debate it it's just like okay that was
clearly wrong but
and those are the only two advantages we
have fundamentally we have the same
hardware right our brains operate in the
same way like we have the same bodies
and the same organs
and so
let's not be like let's not be stupid
with that technology and with that
knowledge let's use it let's be like
okay like here are some things that we
should repeat these are great things
we've inherited from our ancestors and
this has worked really well for society
and we should maybe keep those
institutions going i mean a great
example of this to me is like marriage
marriage and marriage in the family it's
like okay well every country every
culture all across the site for these
hundreds thousands of years they've all
had this institution
and brought children into the world
primarily under this institute and it's
worked well for and places who tried
something totally different
they're not round anymore or they're
very small or whatever it led to chaos
so
that's probably a good idea that maybe
that's something we should keep it
doesn't mean everyone has to get married
or whatever it doesn't need to be
enforced but generally
speaking cool like that's a good
institution and then the stuff that's
bad okay cool like we can we can
jettison that let's keep that let's get
rid of that and this to me is just where
the proper balance between
what people what you could call
conservatism liberalism and
progressivism
is right it's it's you conserve
the things that are working well and
lead to a positive functioning society
and happiness
um
you have liberalism which in its proper
sense allows
prioritizes the rights and freedoms of
the individual you can make your choices
regardless of
you know who you are and these
categories you fit into whatever you ha
you have the free choice to live your
life
as you see fit you have the right to
speak you have the right to practice or
not practice a religion you have the
right to freedom of association so on
right you have your your basic
fundamental rights and then what
progressivism should mean
is okay
look there are still some things that we
need to improve there are things there
are changes that we can make
let's balance these things out and let's
do this let's do this carefully
right let's do this carefully if you're
driving a car
and it's like
you know if someone gets in the car and
is asking you is it better to accelerate
or brake
like well what you know is it best to
turn left or right
so this is the thing right so when
people go to these kind of like radical
ends of of uh say what people call
progressivism it's just change at all
costs just just change everything just
flip the whole thing honestly no get rid
of that it's like bro but that thing
works like why'd you want to get rid of
this stuff it's like no just go just
slam your foot on the accelerator and
it's like dude you're you're gonna crash
there's a wall yeah similarly if you
just like hold down the brake
right just hold the brake no you can't
change anything like no we must conserve
and preserve complete status quo it's
like all right well you don't move
anywhere you don't go forward so
this is actually why
you know i think um
some people won't like me saying this
but this is the value of having dialogue
between people of different
socio-political perspectives and so on
right because there is value and
intelligence
in
each one and they all check each other
right so
the natural conservative tendency is hit
the break right the progressive tendency
is hit the accelerator so it's actually
if you have a sensible dialogue and you
bring people together
then we can have an honest and mature
conversation yeah people are gonna have
people are gonna disagree it might get
you know heated at times and so on it's
not gonna you're never gonna have like
this perfect harmony because people are
different but i think you can
have a good balance where
society
is slowly
improving i think that's generally what
we what we have had i think it's still
what we do have i think we're just in a
like a messy
a very messy phase of it and with the
intro introduction of smartphones and
social media it's made it all far it's
made it faster and it's made it more
chaotic because you now have access to
billions of people's thoughts and
opinions and ideas whereas before that
was all just in people's heads and you
couldn't see it and you can
and then you've got the bot interference
dude
it's nuts especially on your account
i i am going to nominate my account for
the single worst twitter account in
terms of the bot problem it's crazy i uh
i've thought i haven't done it yet uh uh
i did it one time like kind of
half-heartedly but like i thought every
time that i tweet i should just tag the
ceo of twitter so that his notifications
get as many of the bots as mine and the
problem be fixed tomorrow like it's
literally
hundreds
right i went and i looked the other day
uh and i had blocked manually over a
thousand accounts and i went and then
they've been wiping them right so
they're doing something it's just
they're not stopping the ones from
actually getting posted uh and i blocked
a bunch more and i was back up over a
thousand and i was like
i've probably spent hours of my life
fighting hand-to-hand combat on the
internet
with some [ __ ] bot farm
outside the united states somewhere and
there's somebody who's just running a
script and they're like here you go
[ __ ] right like how quick can
you report and block these people yeah
and i'm like i don't know but i'm gonna
try
because the product's unusable without
it it's annoying joe it's also annoying
because it's so easy to fix
that's not a that's not a hard problem
to fix anyone who has cz binance in
their [ __ ] name and isn't the
verified account block them
like okay i just solved 80 of the bot
problem and literally i thought for 10
seconds about it right like
it's so simple yeah i remember when elon
brought up the idea of
verification and people freaked out
because they were are you gonna have to
submit like your social security number
and that's like dude i don't think
that's what he means
i think you're going a little
i understand security number to prove
you're not a bot yeah i don't think he
wants like full-on you know kyc i think
it's just a basic verification of
humanity which in itself could cut down
that nonsense probably by eighty ninety
percent you know it's going to become uh
discriminatory because they're gonna uh
come up with a uh verification for like
celebrities
and then like the common person and uh
doesn't that already exist uh
well if now there's different colored
check marks
right like but this is the game it's
like well why do they get the blue one
find blue people right blue people
and you're like wait what is going on
you know they've haven't they done an
experiment with that where they've just
like given people like different colored
stickers
and sort of really
yeah and and they band together
and start even to some degree start
mistreating
the people who have the general did you
see did you see the wolves and i think
it's yosemite uh national park no
so i don't know exactly how they
captured it but uh there's an image that
i saw going around um and they were able
to track different packs of wolves in
this national park
and you know if you imagine tracking a
pack of wolves it's like a bunch of
lines everywhere right because they're
moving around and must have been for
months if not years
each pack has its own color
okay when you zoom out look at the map
it's like the blue lines are all right
here the pink ones are here the red ones
are here the green ones are here the
yellow ones are here and basically the
takeaway was like the wolves don't [ __ ]
with each other
they stay with their pack and literally
there was no blue going into the red
area like it's almost like gangs right
like just like they knew what the rules
of the road were and they stayed in
their pack
and my takeaway from it was like you
mean to tell me
that it's literally like a genetic
like nash uh natural thing
that people tend to
stay in packs
the wolves do it humans do it all stuff
now again that doesn't mean that you
can't go to another pack doesn't mean
that you can't have social mobility all
these different things but like
there's like a biology conversation
somewhere in there that if the wolves do
it and humans do it
maybe it's not humans
maliciously doing stuff
and again there's exceptions fine
but
that was more eye-opening to me than
anything else that i've seen in this
conversation around like yo you tell me
the wolves do the [ __ ] that humans are
being accused of maybe it's not a human
thing oh dude no it's not at all man
tribalism is a
biological thing
and their tribalism just exists it's not
good nor bad
it's just
it just exists positive and negative
impact from it but it's just the thing
that exists yeah it's a thing that
exists and again if you
if we communicate intelligently and
again i do think that to give props to
most western countries certainly the usa
certainly the uk
have made fantastic headway
in
this direction in
moving away from overly toxic tribalism
i mean you need tribalism because we're
all members of families and communities
and then on top of that we have we have
nationalities people are from cern so
you know that's fine people even what
people support right you people have
their sports teams that they support or
whatever and you can have you know some
fun tribalism there but as soon as you
start like oh you beat somebody up
because they wore the wrong football
jersey or you you know you get like two
levels of hooliganism or you get to as
we've discussed you know racism or like
going let alone going to genocide okay
like the tribalism has gone way way way
too far so
i think the key thing is yeah just
recognizing that that exists and then
what's the best thing you can do i often
think of just going up a level right so
if you think of how tribalism works
we're all members of multiple different
tribes but if you actually go up a level
you gain more commonality
right so
if someone is like getting people are
getting stuck in this tribalism and
division over here it's like wait why
don't you all go up one level and you'll
see what you have in common right and
this this is something that's
particularly crazy when you look at
certain things that have happened in
history or even certain conflicts that
are still going on which are weird i
mean if you
okay
take take the religious line i mean look
at look at um northern ireland
right where's that whole conflict
between the protestants and the
catholics and i'm like bro you're all
christian
and you're all irish you're all irish
christians why are you bombing each
other right or
who is there wrong
they have a slightly different
interpretation of the bible um or
whose most islamic terrorism aimed at
it's it's aimed at other other muslims
right and i'm like man that's
that's so wild that's that shows how
toxically tribal people can get man you
look at obviously people always use the
example of like the holocaust but
something much more recently i mean
94 the rwandan genocide
i don't know how much you know listeners
have looked into that but that's such a
horrible story but
it's like man it shows you the power of
unhinged tribalism and when the media
and politicians get involved in it and
start stoking intentions like these are
all rwandans right you've got tootsies
you've got hutu
and you had about a million people
killed
slaughtered not by a government machine
by their own neighbors
primarily with machetes this is just
1994.
right and people kind of like gloss over
this i think oftentimes things that
happen in africa are glossed over in the
west
they only kind of talk about africa when
it's convenient but when you look at
these stories this is why looking
history is important like i'm not a
historian
but i like to look at stories of history
because
it teaches you really about the human
condition
and because we haven't fundamentally
changed in our hardware and in our
biology it's really important to
recognize that because
and this is why i think it makes people
uncomfortable because if you do it
honestly you realize that you have to
face your own shadow you have to face
the the darkness right everyone wants to
imagine oh if i was in nazi germany i
would have freed the jews i would have
done
the majority the majority yeah there
would be people who would do it
the majority would have either been
nazis
or have been sympathetic to them or have
just kept their heads down that's the
truth and no one wants to even like
how do we know that well because that's
what majority of people did they fell
into one of those three groups yes that
that's just what happens and so
one reason why i'm even how i am
is because i've really thought about a
lot of this stuff
i've really thought about i've looked at
the i've read the gulag archipelago i've
read ordinary man i've read certain
things and looked at even certain
studies the milgram experiment you know
ash experiment and saying okay
the dynamics when people are in groups
or in tribes like this can lead to this
really loopy and even very dark and
violent stuff
so
even when i was in my say in my my 20s i
was thinking okay if i were ever in
this kind of situation
what are my boundaries and principles
and how should i
how should i behave because
there's this group think thing that
happens
and there's when fear takes over
and i'm just like okay i need to think
about this and i've spent a lot of time
kind of doing that
mental work of like okay hopefully in my
lifetime
nothing
that bad is ever going to happen or be
coming down the pipeline but if it does
these are the things to be aware of and
you understand how the fear takes over
and how the social pressure takes over
and how you know the authorities
even even just the way people defer to
authority
which can
again it's not always something that's
inherently bad right we all need we all
need to be able to be leaders sometimes
and followers sometimes right and if
we're being honest even people who are
leaders you probably spend more time
following than leading for them for the
most part so
it's not that deference to authority is
is a bad thing but the authority has to
be
has to be good has to be valid has to be
legitimate and you can't just
you know what's that well those magic
words i was just following orders right
that that doesn't cut it right there
comes a time where you have to be like
no
i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna do this thing that
completely goes against my morals or my
ethics or my values just because i was
told to and that line is different for
different people but i do recommend
people think about it and have one so
there's uh people who get put in the
position right and they can choose
whether to uh follow either side of that
line um but there's been a
larger resurgence i don't know if you
could say it's large but it's growing of
people who are starting to speak out
about all kinds of stuff obviously uh
the pandemic was kind of a wake-up call
for lots and lots of people and they
were like wait hold on a second this
kind of crazy stuff um
one of the people andrew tate yep took
the world by storm
uh
and then essentially got kicked off all
social media platforms yep what do you
think about the state of de-platforming
and censorship and like
how bad is it right yeah free top g man
um
before i answer that question it's
actually been really fascinating to see
that because i had him on my podcast in
february 2019
um and then i s i visited him and his
brother in romania in 2020 and i was
hanging out with him in dubai actually
earlier this year so
it's interesting when somebody who you
know
becomes this sort of like global
conversation and you're seeing like 90
of what i read about him online is wrong
which is interesting because i'm like
i know this guy like what like people
are just saying crazy stuff so
um but yeah in terms of d platforming
it's
it sucks man
honestly it sucks it's extraordinarily
illiberal
um it's actually
dude i mean
again i i don't think people think about
this stuff deeply enough
they deplatformed
the former president of the united
states of america
from multiple platforms simultaneously
i don't care whether you like trump
dislike trump what
that is
insane that should
freak you out
like that should free like i don't he
technically was still president when
they did it he was still the the sitting
president of the united states someone
bad twitter instagram facebook like in a
coordinated you know off of a very fuzzy
notion
that he i mean he didn't direct he
didn't call for violence he didn't
actually people oh well he broke you
can't even like people just repeat stuff
people just parrot stuff but
here's here's a here's another issue
that happened the sitting part by the
way yeah is like when people were like
oh it happened i think some people were
like
he's still not allowed back on
but the sitting president of the united
states of america
and again
if they were to go and do it to joe
biden yeah i would still be just as much
as yeah
hold on because it becomes a thing where
who's in charge dude it's crazy
like
wait what
yeah dude anyone who celebrated that
you're a dummy if you if you celebrated
trump being de-platformed
you are a fool because it goes back to
the idea of uh
never use a tool that you wish for your
enemy to never uh to never have access
to
right and so like
if twitter got sold and they went and
they hired somebody
and uh they wanted to go after all the
democrats
i think there'd be a lot of people oh
[ __ ] yeah right and so it doesn't it's
not a political left or right thing to
me it's just
again there are exceptions of if you
call for violence if you do certain
things okay got it
but it feels like uh
there's this world of just like
you got too much power as a user
and i think that you know if you look at
uh tate
it's not very clear to me as to like why
he got taken off all these things no do
you know i mean i sp i spoke to him the
day that it happened because i had
called him immediately i was like dude
like what the heck just happened
um this is when he you know he his
youtube had his it was just his
instagram and facebook okay but you know
his youtube hadn't been taken down and
so on and then you know that came a
follow a couple days later
um do you know coincidence yeah but
this is this it's important for people
to understand this because
he did not violate he he didn't post
anything the violated policies you know
the policy they banned him under no was
the um
dangerous individuals or organizations
so if you think why does this policy
exist this policy exists so that the the
ku klux klan
can't have an official instagram page
this this exists so that's um al-qaeda
cannot be putting out recruitment videos
on on youtube etc that's why you know
dangerous
persons and organizations so they've
essentially thrown him in that same
category with the worst like actual
terrorists actual murderers actual
genocidal maniacs because
they and this is how they weaponize
these words the words they weapon
some of the most dangerous words being
used these days are dangerous safety
harm and harmful
that's how they always phrase it right
it's always oh we need to protect you we
need to protect you right all this is
harmful is this misinformation this is
this oh this is harmful you made that
person feel unsafe you probably saw the
other day about you know the from the
podcast thing when bench did you see the
one with ben shapiro no you didn't see
you didn't see the whole the podcast
thing in dallas no where someone's like
someone's laughing
yo
oh my gosh oh he went to the conference
there's a conference where he showed up
to a conference and then they said uh
people felt unsafe because
i didn't see it we apologize for the the
harm his presence caused
his presence just that's a powerful
[ __ ] a five foot eight jewish
man in kapaa or you know
standing there
after his organization spent 30 grand to
rent a booth and sponsor the event
dude
the whole thing is wild but this is the
weaponization of language right during
during the pandemic why were they
kicking people are these are harmful
spreading harmful disinformation
misinformation there's people who
literally put out facts
right they do platform doctors they do
platform scientists just oh harmful
misinformation and so that sort of
safety language
it's how they de-platform trump it's how
they de-platform tape prior to this by
the way because i've been on twitter
since 2009. so i remember when this all
started because for the first
up until about 2014 2015 no one no one
worried about getting d platforms that's
when they got uh what was alex jones
alex jones but then there was another
kevin mcginnis another conservative guy
with the uh milo yiannopoulos
um yeah there were there were like a
bunch of them it was all people on the
right yep you know and they always start
with the people who are more
objectionable
right so again people now there's these
dummies celebrating andrew tate's band
it's like oh
so okay you considered him on okay a
couple years ago they considered alex
jones on the fringe and they considered
um milo yiannopoulos and oh they were
they were on the right right now you
consider andrew
do dummies not realize that as that
closes in you at some point are going to
be standing
on the edge of that island as it's
crumbling all around you
um you know that the youtube video we
put up of uh andrew tate the title was
entertaining the new options yeah
because it was so obvious really an
interview by the way that that was going
to be the game it's just like oh you're
saying things are outside and i i joke
about like oh that somebody's saying too
much truth right where they're trying to
shapiro tate whatever uh but you know
what the most telling part of the entire
andrew tate situation to me was tell me
this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep good sleep is a game changer and
the eight sleep pod is the best sleep
machine i sleep on it every single night
a great night of sleep allows you to be
healthier be more arrested and have more
energy throughout the day and on the
brand new eight sleep pod 3 you can
sleep as cold as 55 degrees fahrenheit
or as hot as 110 degrees fahrenheit
that's the secret of thermoregulation
better sleep better energy get yourself
innate sleep you can go to hsleep.com
pomp today to go ahead and get 150 off
your order aidsleep.com
not only do i sleep on it every night it
literally changed my life and i begged
the founders to let me invest in the
company eightsleep.com
go get yourself an eight-sleep pod and
get a better night of sleep he came out
the last myth the last message an hour
hour and ten minute video
it came out and i said you know what i
owe this guy
my
time
he did a bunch of stuff he said what and
all his stuff and everything people have
been asking me hey you met him what did
he like all stuff and everything right
and i said
the fact that somebody would ask me that
tells me that you're a critical thinker
right because you're like hey i see all
the stuff on the internet but what's he
really like let me talk to somebody who
at least talk to him because i can't
talk to him or whatever it's like okay
cool but then i'd be at dinner and other
people be chirping and you know seeing
all this crazy [ __ ] and everything and i
just sit there nicely it's a human
trafficker
you just have no clue right you have no
clue because you're you have an opinion
about somebody that you've never spoken
to before so when that came out i took
it and um a bunch of these group chats
and stuff with people who you know for
generally have big audiences or
influence or whatever and i put it in
there i said listen whether you like
this person or not whatever your
preconceived notion is watch this yeah
see what you think if you want to watch
it because you think that this is the
21st century way of communication and
this is like you know uh uh you're
studying the tactics not the the content
cool you'll get some value out of it
but if you actually want to know
more about the person watch this
and
i'd love to hear what you guys all think
i can't tell you how many people
responded to this that i don't have time
to watch it yeah of course is that it's
our oh i don't have that and they just
didn't even look at it yeah but then
they kept i saw them they're still
sharing opinions about it everything and
i said look
i don't expect people to defend somebody
they don't know i don't also expect
people to go back to kind of the
beginning or conversation
have some crazy opinion either way or
whatever
but if you do have an opinion yes yo
yourself be informed yeah go get the
information and another thing is you
know people need to stop this thing of
conflating
defending you know like i like to say
i'll i don't i'll i will defend andrew
tate himself
but
not that he needs me to he can defend
himself um but
you can defend it's defend principles
there are principles if you are someone
with principles and values if you are if
you believe in the concept of freedom of
speech
right not just on a legal level not just
on this narrow legal level but it's
actually a cultural issue too freedom of
speech is not supposed to just be a
legal concept it's also a social and
cultural concept right you could if you
have if if you have freedom of speech
so-called protected under the law but
like society societally and culturally
it's
absolutely not tolerated then you don't
really have it if people are terrified
to speak and say basic things then
you're not supporting freedom of speech
so
anyone who i whether i i doesn't my
personal feelings about the person or
what they're saying whether i agree with
them politically or i don't care i will
defend the principle of someone having a
right to voice what they want to voice
for a huge number of reasons
another thing that's also been getting
lost
in our in our society and maybe
i don't know i don't i don't know if
this is linked to the to the loss of
religion because it can you know
religion can also overly be used to kind
of push the opposite but
forgiveness and salvation
right
this is one of the i don't think
like yes you're sure of social media
private company you can do whatever you
want like bro i'm largely libertarian
like i'm not even arguing that but just
because you can do something doesn't
mean you should this cuts in all
directions and also you need to give
people a pathway
to people change
you need to give people a pathway to
forgiveness and salvation and
understanding and so on
if you just i mean even the the proper
legal system understands this
right there are people who have
killed people who are walking free
there's people who have raped robbed
burgled people who are walking for they
served their time they spent 25 years in
prison
they did their whole sentence
fingers crossed they actually reformed
and they changed and now they're an
integrated productive member of society
get you don't condemn the person forever
oh you stole something when you were 17
we're gonna lock you up forever in jail
and we're going to throw away the key oh
you have but if you tweet if you tweet
bad things
you don't get to come back i don't think
i don't permanent bands shouldn't exist
i know that social media is not
everything but bro like majority of the
world is on social media billions of
people use it it's where the
conversations happen so the idea that
you said something in 2014
which twitter felt crosstalk and so
never again
can you use that that is insane to me
bro
that's crazy even if you did actually
cross the line how about okay
one year ban you know one year ban after
that you know you learn yes you can you
can come back and play nice but the idea
that you just kick people off forever
especially to do it so arbitrarily to me
is i think it sets a i think it sends a
really bad message and i think also and
this has been studied i know that the
guys at minds.com studied this um
they're great
it radicalizes people more of course it
radicalizes people more how do you get
someone to change their mind you have to
talk to them like i understand trust me
i understand that having conversations
with certain people is not fun and it's
not right like there's people out there
who are just so far gone i'm like dude i
don't wanna i don't wanna sit down and
really have a conversation with like an
actual
white supremacist or something right but
that's the only way to get them to
change their views you have to hear them
out you have to rebut them you have to
talk i believe that good ideas
ultimately win if you don't censor i do
believe the good ideas generally will
generally will float to the top not all
the time not 100
but you let people voice their stuff you
let them have their concerns you can
correct them on this you can debate this
and so just censoring that person and
pushing them out to the corner
and then who do they go hang with and
who are they conversing with right
they're just with the other banned
people right that's one of the problems
you've had with some of the um
alternative social media platforms
especially something like gab right
because it's like become the home of
everyone everyone who got kicked off
of everything else now it goes to this
one platform and it's like it's not it's
not moderated at all it's just like okay
well you can kind of just say whatever
on there and people are going to like
back you up and reinforce that and so
you believe it's even more and more true
and it it increases the polarization
it's not helping i think
there's this natural tendency as human
beings
when we see or we hear something we
don't like like i understand censorship
because it's not hard to understand if
someone
says something that that offends you or
you don't like or you have a visceral
reaction to the natural inclination is
to want to shut that person up
right you you you that's the that's the
first urge that's like the biological
urges shut this person up get them out
of my sight i don't i don't even want to
talk to them i don't in fact they
shouldn't even be allowed to say what
they're saying i get where that tendency
comes from but
we have to be able to fight it because
ultimately
in this country you've got about 340
million people in this world we've got
about 8 billion people no two people are
the same there's no two people on this
planet who agree on absolutely
everything it doesn't exist we are all
different we have our different
social views cultural views
personalities religious views political
like we're we're just we're different
right it's a good thing yes and and it's
a good thing and it's and it's fine and
we need to be able to co-exist
right so if i look at a country like the
usa i talk about the u.s law i'm here
right now um
but also it is the usa truly is a leader
i don't know if americans always
understand just how much
when people call the usa the leader of
the free world that's not just a cute
name that's actually what it is
right other countries across europe
australia canada the uk they take cues
from the usa even non-western countries
take cues from the usa so what happens
in the usa
does matter right whether it's the music
that becomes popular here becomes
popular in other countries the ideas
that become popular here often become
popular in other places and so that's
why because some americans don't go oh
like you know mind your own business why
are you talking about the u.s and it's
like dude because it impacts everyone it
impacts everyone and you've got such a
big population
um
and oh man sorry i'm losing my what was
the initial point i was i was going to
make what yes people need to be able to
coexist yeah right if you're going to
have all that diversity in every true
sense of the word
then you need a way of
having things you need not just you need
a legal structure obviously but also
culture changes
and things that were not previously
acceptable
become acceptable yes
and in reverse so there's a lot of
people who uh the mob came for because
of things they said in 2000
and uh i always remind folks you want to
know the single best way uh that i found
especially men
um but but uh to figure out how much
culture has changed
go on youtube
and search
the man show
jimmy kimmel
and adam kroll they had a show comedy
central
this show
it called the man show it was for men
yeah
it had women
in like bikinis jumping on trampolines
they were drinking beer and doing dude
[ __ ] yeah right
i told somebody that this show existed
like that [ __ ] never was on television i
said it was on [ __ ] regular gable
like it wasn't a pay-per-view you know
it was like literally if you just like
had the cable at the house you could get
the show and they were like no way so we
went the first the very first episode
from this show is on uh youtube you will
watch five minutes of this big how did
they ever air it
you're literally like there's no like
what were they thinking yeah but it's
because of a different time yeah and so
obviously what was okay then
is now viewed as not okay okay but the
reverse happens there's things that you
couldn't say three years ago
that now you can say
and so if somebody was punished or
kicked off or whatever
how do you accommodate or or account for
what if things change and now what
they're saying is like an accepted thing
and zero hedge was uh was probably the
example where we saw this most
they were the first talk about the lab
league
kicked off immediately the second they
got kicked off i was like
somebody's gonna have to find out some
more information on this
now we have politicians
i i would argue that actually there's
the most common theory now a number of
politicians who think it's the most
likely the most likely theory and so
again they got reinstated and and all
this stuff but like imagine if they'd
been kicked off of any platform and not
allowed back it was a permanent ban
and then all of a sudden three years
later we're like oh yeah everyone thinks
this
yeah how do you bring them back
yeah i agree man that's the that's the
salvation component i think a big part
of it also is just
maturity i think a lot about
like
how mature we are as a society and i
think that
we've been
some of this stems from the comfort you
alluded to earlier
but we are
we've had a lot of infantilization
of adults over the past few decades
to a level that is where people cannot
handle and regulate their own emotions i
call it emotional incontinence
and
we essentially are catering to the most
neurotic
most
scaredy cat most easily offended most
easily triggered
people it's like it's like a
race to the bottom
and instead of trying to encourage
people to become
more
resilient and strong mentally physically
and emotionally
we're trying to nerf the whole world
right so instead of
so
instead of telling the person who
wants to cry
because
someone called them
not their preferred pronoun
instead of telling that person like
look man
be strong it's not it's not it's not the
end of the world right people talk like
people generally refer to people based
on the biological gender that they think
they are and so like
bro like get over it just get over it
instead it's like oh no we need
to get 99.9 of people who never had
any issue ever
with how pronouns are used now you all
need we need to change the entire
english language and your understanding
of it to cater to this not even 0.1
of people right like this one guy on
twitter got offended so we all need to
cater to by the way we had the same
thing during the pandemic
right instead of just going okay look
there's a certain segment of the
population that's particularly
vulnerable to this disease and there
should be certain accommodations and
perhaps policies and
things put in place for them instead
it's like no we need to treat everyone
the same right we
because this there's this
you know one percent of people
100 percent of you need to completely
sideline your entire lives for two years
because of this thing by the way
how offended people would have been if
they said old people
and unhealthy people
and you
were
anything below the age of 60 and you
were just you know do you know who
wouldn't have been offended old people
of course isn't that funny of course the
people who are most vulnerable
i i remember early i remember early on
when i was in the u.s people like yo
i remember i remember whenever uh you
know whenever i was like
going around masculists like the rebel i
am like the other people i see not
wearing masks were almost always over
60.
of course it was hilarious like i'd be
in the supermarket you know all the
everyone in like from teenagers to 40s
they're you know all wearing their masks
and then i'm just seeing like some old
guy or some old woman just going around
with them
like no one even like was there ever a
poll done on elderly people asking if
they even all this was done supposedly
in their name it's like do they even
want that is that even
like why can't they take care of
themselves but again it's this
infantilization and that because that's
how you treat children you don't let
children make all their own choices you
don't even tell that you don't even get
to choose what you eat for breakfast
maybe maybe we'll have two cereals and
you can pick one right but
that's what their that's how they're
treating
adults now right there's there's this
loss of
idea of
adults are mature and therefore you can
give them a level of autonomy and
liberty and freedom and ability to make
their own choices and so on it's like no
we need to
take that away and be more authoritarian
because we can't trust the people to
make their own decisions and i think
that people need to stop playing into
that and i think that when you
encourage this censorship or
safe spaces or de-platforming everyone
you disagree with or whatever and you're
discouraging
conversation and debate and discourse
then
it
it furthers the problem and you are
appeasing again you're appeasing
the weakest links
of course you're appeasing the weakest
links and we've never done that before
we've gone from survival of the fittest
to tyranny of the weakest speaking of
survival of the fittest what's up with
the secretary of state in the uk uh our
secretary of health uh oh the new one
the new one uh she doesn't look healthy
uh yeah and uh then i saw a lineup of a
bunch of uh secretary of health across
all these countries and a lot of them
don't look very healthy now i don't
think that arnold schwarzenegger is the
expectation right of like somebody who's
like a bodybuilder or like super super
fit because they do nothing but work out
all day
but there is some irony to the fact that
uh
a number of people who supposedly are in
charge of the health of
tens of millions hundreds of millions of
people
may not actually be healthy themselves
no we don't live in serious countries
bro
[Laughter]
let's make them really not healthy
that'd be funny
it's it's weird man it's weird i often
it's it's strange because it's it's
across the world i mean do you remember
the old one from belgium
yes
like i and this isn't me trying to be
mean to people
but
if you are here here's a controversial
opinion i think that if you are a
personal trainer or a health secretary
or a health sick i think you should be
in shape
like
i mean i don't think that's too much to
ask for i feel the same when i say like
an obese personal trainer and i'm like
um
like practice what you appreciate if i'm
gonna hire a financial advisor and they
are like broken massively in debt
uh
see when you say it this way people like
oh this is ridiculous warren buffett
who's like somehow has escaped all of
the mob whatever
one of his like famous quotes is wall
street is the only place where
millionaires ride in nice cars to go get
advice from people who wrote the subway
um
right like basically
the rich people are getting advice from
people who may not be rich and again i
don't think that uh
take money as an example to be a
financial advisor you have to be rich
and like
yeah like richer than your clients but
like
it goes back to like maybe you just need
to have good financial habits yeah and
guess what if you have good financial
habits you will eventually build you
should some level of wealth yes you
shouldn't be ultra broken same thing
with fitness you don't have to be the
bodybuilder right you don't want to be
an ulcer marathon
but like
be generally eating healthy be generally
taking care of yourself uh in whatever
way like if somebody if a health
minister or whatever you want to call
them right was like you know what i go
for a 30-minute walk every day i eat
healthy and uh generally feel good and
uh and all that great like that's what
works for that person
they seem to care it is they're like
putting things into practice and by the
way that's gonna be the message it's
also just modeling
you know it's it's role modeling man i
mean bro i've written two fitness books
if
like just that alone means i can't be
out of shape
like like even from my own perspective
if i'm ever like i'm like bro i
literally wrote fitness but like i tell
people about fitness i cannot
let myself go right
like that's embarrassing dude it's like
bro like you're not even like why don't
you read your own book and take you like
it's just like
it's such a it's such a basic thing but
people on the internet also live uh you
you grow accustomed to the trolls yeah
so like like before you tweet something
you like pretty much know like oh here's
what the trolls will say or like hey let
me say it in a way that takes away their
like argument or whatever i think that
those same people in the real world like
you know right you're like if i get out
of shape some troll will read your own
book
like so like there's this like
conditioning that happens where you're
constantly always just like all right i
have that troll in my own head like that
that's why i'm awesome you're good at
what you do because you're like oh i
[ __ ] know what you trolls i got your
argument already i'll hold myself
accountable before before anybody else
does but man politics is so weird though
in that regard because
i don't
i don't know like i flip-flop between
thinking the whole thing is just kind of
a game or an illusion or like it's real
i don't know but
i i believe i feel like any every
american i know
all of my american acquaintances or
friends
i believe would be a better president
than the current one all of them i think
you'd be a better person than the job
but i think everyone your staff i think
so
i'm always how even when you look at
like the mayor level or the you know i
think
um
florida well we're in florida miami and
florida both have you know good um
mayors and and governors i believe um
but like around the country i just see
some of the mayors and some of the guys
they're so goofy i'm just like
how is this person like how did this
person
become
the leader because i'll go to the city
or whatever and i'm like bro like you
you you you like any of you could do
this better have you seen uh there's one
race uh specifically um i think it's in
pennsylvania i wanna say it's in
congress maybe they got uh
two guys and i pay so little attention
to this that i'm definitely afraid of
wrong uh but i think it's this guy john
uh fetterman and dr oz yes and the only
reason why uh i know those two guys are
running against each other is because
somebody took a video of dr oz like
yelling and screaming whatever about the
other guy and the jon fetterman guy
yelling screaming about him and they put
it like back to back and they were like
dude what the [ __ ] is going on here and
it's just like
man those are the two choices that some
group of people have
and like i don't know what their
policies are i don't know like anything
right
but it wasn't exactly like a video that
made me be like you know what i need to
wake up and be better yeah and i think
that's part of this whole like role
model thing is
i think again uh people will debate
presidents if you start at the top
used to be
aspirational in the sense of
people wanted that job yes people felt
like you had to be a good citizen moral
like all these things to get that job
and the president made the nation
want to be better yes
and the way that the nation wants to be
better is the individual
feels like that like well that sounds a
lot like [ __ ] leadership but put that
aside
i feel like there are very few people in
the world today
that are in
traditional positions of power or
influence
that have that impact i agree now it's
people on the internet with like a
[ __ ] cell phone who like are doing
selfie videos
and so to me like that's a pretty
interesting dynamic where we shifted
from like all this centralized control
and power and influence all stuff and
like those that's what the aspirational
role model you know uh type relationship
was
now people are running to like this
other thing yeah and they're still
getting it like i don't know
jocko wilnik
versus like the president of the united
states
like
well he's probably more actionable for
the everyday person in terms of like you
know wake up take responsibility you
know whatever
i don't even very many presidents were
like make your bed right
[Laughter]
but like
that's still a pretty big shift to me
yeah and it feels like we just like oh
yeah yes these people are are important
now and we just don't even worry at all
about uh
uh the fact that the people in power
aren't yeah and that extends to
traditional celebrities as well and i
think this is i think long term this is
actually good okay i i think for
some people
regardless of what people say most
people are
not huge fans of change
um
regardless of what they think like most
people don't actually love having
drastic changes and
we're living through a
totally unique period in human history
right now and i think this is part of
why it feels so it's why we're having
this conversation it's why if stuff
feels so
chaotic and confusing and deranging and
destructive because there's this weird
reordering
that is going on there are
institutions and positions and things
that have existed forever and they're
losing
the power and centralization that they
had you see this in the media
you've just talked about it in politics
even in celebrity culture or who's
deemed an influencer right before you
had to go through the proper channels
there were always gatekeepers whether
you're a musician you're an actor you're
a comedian you're this you had to go
through very certain things right to be
a celebrity even 40 years ago
you know they were not like independent
musician celebrities or of course there
were no youtubers or podcasters what it
was like okay you've got news anchors
and you've got uh you know the people in
the political levels and you've got the
hollywood celebrities and you've got
this and that and if you talk to the
younger generation
already the shift has happened
because they know youtubers and
tick-tockers and instagrammers
and actually recognize them more than
they recognize what we consider
traditional celebrities a hundred
percent right and also they aspire more
to that there aren't that many young
people you'll talk to and be like oh i
want to be an actor or i want to do i
want to be a youtuber i want to be um
you know i want to be an influencer now
some people might not like that because
they might think it's weird and those
aren't real jobs or whatever but
my point is that there's this
creative destruction
which is happening i actually think a
lot of it started i think the music
industry was one of the first things
that got massively disrupted by the
internet and by social media and so on
50 cent broke the music business 50 cent
and everyone forgets that 50 cent broke
the heat
the mixtape
and he also had a website and he was
leaking his own music on his own website
he was reading the comments and then he
was basically going back and saying okay
let's not release that one it's not you
know uh the audience doesn't like it
let's do something else or whatever but
like that eventually became what music
did and he was one of the first people
to realize it yeah and it's all because
columbia records dropped on the night
that he got shot yep and so
this has happened this is happening we
see it happen with you know digital
photography with film industry now you
know
dude blockbuster could have bought
netflix when it was cheap
right i mean blockbuster doesn't exist
anymore so just in our own i mean if you
just look in our own relatively short
lifetimes
the shifts we've had are in
sane
absolutely insane and so
i mean if you even in just in the last
10 years so
while
i have many concerns and we all have
concerns and we're worried about this
and that even with stuff like the
de-platforming right
i think a solution will be worked out
long term like right now it sucks right
now it's like dude like what's going on
why are they doing this why don't they
know how to moderate properly i think
part of why they don't sure they have
their political biases right and there
can be some malice involved but also
it's like this is new
this is a new problem i don't think that
when jack dorsey met made twitter or
when mark zuckerberg makes it i don't
think they had
a clue they were going to be as big as
they are
there is no way on earth mark zuckerberg
thought oh three billion people
are gonna be there's over three billion
no dude he was like hot or not
half the world's population uses your
product
that's insane and they're all talking
they're talking like
sure there's moderation issues we cannot
but that's not easy
that's not an easy task to just be like
okay like this is exactly
the way
you do it you're gonna have new things
popping up myspace was the big thing
when i was starting out in music like
new things are going to come in this is
going to come in that's going to become
bigger that's going to become smaller
and
i think one thing that's great is that
we are having this actual increased
democratization did i say the word right
um
where anybody you i anybody out there we
can build you can build your own
platform you can become a a well-known
person or a celebrity in your
own right we're getting all these
instead of just having a handful of
hollywood celebrities or a handful of
actors or athletes or whatever it's like
yeah you still got that but now you've
just got there's like millions of micro
influencers and micro celebrities and
people are finding that i think overall
that's really good it's creating new
jobs
new creative outlets new ways of doing
things i'll tell you something that i
think is going to be massively disrupted
by this and
i don't think that the legacy version is
prepared and i can't wait for this to
happen actually this is an area where
i'd like where i'm a progressive
uh education
education in higher education
we're still running off the fumes
of
this
centuries-old
academic model both in schools and at
universities
and as we're seeing as the cost of
university continues to increase
while the value of a degree continues to
decrease
that's not sustainable you can't keep
having
the value of a degree staying the same
or decreasing as the financial cost goes
up and up and up and up every year
as well as you're having this whole
digital revolution going on
it's gonna move it's it's it has to
change it has to shift just like the
music industry was forced through this
change just like the film industry was
forced through this change just like um
other things are happening right we're
we're bitcoin guys right the mu the
financial industry is gonna is being
disrupted and is going through this
change it's gonna happen with education
and that will be the person and that
will be good the one thing
that the legacy still has
is what i would call
it's funny of me saying this as an
oxford graduate um
perceived legitimacy
right so
the average person and lots of this is
an overhang from older generations
so many people still think have this
mentality of oh you know you have to go
to college even employers have this so
many people will say oh well you have to
go to college because employers have say
you need a degree to get it's like
that's going to change it's already
changing with certain companies most
companies driven by younger people don't
care about your degree they care about
what you can do and your personality and
so on so that whole i think in the next
decade or two
the whole education
system especially in higher education is
going to be
much
more
fragmented and decentralized the thing
that needs to be worked out online i
believe and this will take time is the
accreditation
the accreditation and then with that the
perceived legitimacy
that comes with it so as someone who
went to oxford university even though
like a day-to-day thing i don't use my i
don't use my degree for anything that i
do
but
just the fact if i ever wanted to go
back into the traditional world of work
which i don't um
the fact i have a an oxford university
degree on a global level that is
recognized as oh wow this guy this guy
is smart there's the prestige with it
and and and that's and that's cool
that's cool um
but
and i will say this myself
the thing really should be like well
what are your capabilities what can you
done what have you done right it's not
having an oxford degree that makes me
smart or makes me capable or makes me
competent or anything it's it's it's who
i am and the way my brain works and the
way that i operate
um
so yeah it's cool to have that box
ticked but
i think as time goes on with it i think
it'll take a couple generations for this
shift to happen and for there maybe to
be
online equivalence
in terms of perceived legitimacy as the
oxfords and the harvards and the
cambridges and the yales and so on
that'll take some time because these
institutions are old i mean oxford is
oxford is about
i want to say about
600 years older than the usa
my college was founded in the 1100s
yeah right that is crazy it was founded
in the 1100s right and so you know
you've got people from you know c.s
lewis to jr tolkien to all these
prime ministers and so on who who went
through those halls so i don't think
that's going to completely go away
but i think that the
i think that you know when it comes to
university stem
stem is going to be there and it's going
to stay and certain universities can
stay but
there's so much that's ripe for
not just
disruption but i'd say destruction i
think there's a lot of nonsense out
there that
is you know
just nonsense degrees yeah
nonsense degrees at nonsense
universities that are not helping anyone
they're kind of glorified ponzi schemes
as far as i'm aware because the only
thing you can
use to you only way you can make money
with them is to either get a fake job or
become
someone who then goes back into academia
and teaches everyone about you know
lesbian dance theory
um you know they're not real degrees
they don't help anyone they don't do
anything of value to society so
i think those are going to those are
going to naturally go you know you let
the free market happen yeah and you know
the most dangerous person in america is
oh
it's along these lines of disruption so
it's not education but it's it's media
okay joe rogan rogan yeah the reason
being not for what most people think of
the audience size yes that is important
but because he's willing to have the
conversations yeah that
nowhere else basically will with that
size of audience but do you want to know
what my prediction is for somebody who
will become one of the most dangerous
people in america
andrew schultz
interesting because
one he's got uh the protection of being
a comedian there's a lot of say things
in society that many other people cannot
say
uh
second
is
his weapon of choice is his mind
he's willing to
go direct to the people
and it's the number one thing that
scares the [ __ ] out of the centralized
institutions yeah so if you're sitting
there and you know for those that don't
know he
uh he sold one special sold a second one
they wanted to edit out some jokes he
said now i'll buy it back from you
and i'll just go direct and i'll set up
a website to andrew schultz.com and i'll
sell directly to the people and he
claims that he made more than five times
more money than if he'd done it with a
streamer i believe that if you're
sitting there and you're a streamer you
have to be absolutely shaking in fear
that he just basically red-pilled a
bunch of these comedians
that say
why would i come to you
why don't i just go direct yeah and then
i have the contact information of the
audience i can remarket to them i can do
all these things i can sell them tickets
i can do like like i just cut you out of
the process
and now me and my people we communicate
directly yeah
that's like the new
danger
in
society is these people who are willing
to think differently and can
disrupt these
institutions these uh mechanisms
because it's not about the first person
who does it because technically even
schultz wasn't the first one to do it
right there other other people have done
it
before
but the people who popularized the
strategy
everyone who follows and so when you
think of things like you know youtube or
whatever it's like there was one person
who was the first actor who was like oh
i'm not going to act in a movie i'm
going to act on the internet and another
then another another and then mr beast
comes along
and now people are like
yo mr piece is bigger than the movie
studios
and there's a bunch of young kids like i
won't be the next mr beast in my own you
know whatever and so it's like to the
movie industry the biggest threat is
actually mr beast yeah he got more views
than squid games got on netflix good and
so you're sitting in the sand like oh
[ __ ] yep that one
video is not the threat
it's that he just red pilled an entire
generation of kids you don't have to go
do the movie theater yeah i love it do
you do you know who worked this out
early who rappers
independent rappers
explain like
independent rappers back in the 90s who
would just
hustle their music independently right
whether you're talking about
too short or ludicrous before the record
deal or you know later 50 cent with the
mixtape hustle a lot of the guys in the
south a lot of the guys from like
houston
um some of the berry rappers there was
just this
thing you know even how jay-z even
started right like print up your own
record market it and sell it yourself
and i mean that's that's where i took my
inspiration from i mean i don't know how
much you know about my
my story of how i like built up my music
right yeah on the streets well the whole
uk the whole uk so
when i was at oxford i started rapping
when i was in my first year of
university um i released my first album
when i was 19 in my in my second year it
was an album called commercial
underground and
the first ever run i did i just did i
did a run of 50 cds to begin with and i
just sold those to friends and family
boom in a week they were all sold i went
back took that money cool printed 250.
um
similar
word was getting around primarily sorted
around people in my university and then
boom i took that money and printed a
thousand
and at this point i'd exhausted my
yeah people i knew
and i bought cds off people in the
street before like if i'm walking around
in london or central london you know i'd
meet guys and london rappers and i'd buy
cds off of them i knew about the mixtape
hustle that was going on in the usa and
so on and i bought mixtapes in the usa
when i traveled here
um
i was like ah that's what i'll do so i
remember i'm the first day ever i went
you know i went out on the street i
think i just had like
six cds with me or something and i was
like okay let me just try this out and i
think it took like half an hour before i
even approached anybody because i'm like
there was like whoa
this is people see me now and they're
like oh wow you'd be so extroverted and
confident but it's like man like that's
cause i've had hundreds and thousands of
conversations and but you know i
remember i think the third person i
spoke to bought bought my album for like
five pounds and i was like oh wow let's
set up the lab i was like wow i sold one
that means i can sell another you know
within a couple hours within like two
hours you know i sold all the cds i came
back i came back uh the next day you
know i bought 10 cds with me boom i sold
10 cds i made 50 pounds i was like okay
this is what i can do and then over time
i started doing that all over the
country right i would travel all the way
to scotland i'd go to wales i went to
the isle away i'm going to east anglia
all over the uk every city and i was
just selling my cds i've sold i sold
over 30 000 albums hand-to-hand jesus
out of my backpack just me hand to hand
do you how many people have to talk to
to sell 3000 like
dude that's what i did 10 000 at a time
so that was my bro i learned i learned
to speak french i learned to speak
spanish because i was because in the uk
you get people from all over europe so i
was like man i keep bumping into french
people and i'm sure i like taught myself
french i was like there i'd have days
i'm just speaking french all day selling
my cds to all these french kids in
oxford or in canterbury or whatever and
then um in 2014 uh with my with my
friend shadow who's also an independent
rapper we started uh what was called the
the blue and purple store
so it was a pop-up shop so you you know
on shopping malls sometimes if you're
walking through they've got the little
kiosks and stores and independent
retailers selling their stuff so we
started doing that we opened the first
one at the white lease shopping center
in london and we were selling our cds
and also our t-shirts and hats we didn't
have that much merch at the time um
and that went well and then we opened
one in like west key and southam we
started doing pop-up shops so rather
than just being on the street all the
time
we moved indoors crappy british weather
too so we were protected from the
elements uh in fact when it started
raining it was good because everyone
would come into the mall yeah
so we'd be there we started selling our
hoodies our t-shirts i used to have my
own brand of headphones and that became
the bread and butter for me from
2014 to 2018
uh or even early 2019 the majority of my
income was coming through doing those
pop-up shops interesting so one thing
that a lot what what's weird with my
career trajectory is over
probably 99 of people who know me
discovered me
since 2019
but i released my first job in 2006.
so i've been going for a long long time
so by it's funny now people see me doing
certain things or whatever like oh this
guy you know came out of nowhere ever
over and i'm like dude like i've been
grinding counting yeah like half my life
like i've been
you know i put out my first album 19. oh
bro like i'm man i'm 36 now i'm just
like dude like it doesn't even seem that
long but i've just been out there
grinding and with that
has come
you know
thankfully one thing people often say
like man zoopy like you've got away with
words you're so good at talking to
people like bro i've spoken to more
people than anybody
or when people are like oh how do you
deal with uh how do you deal with people
saying mean things on the internet how
do you deal with it i'm like dude i used
to sell my cds on the street
you ever heard somebody say something
mean to you in person for a decade i
would just be out there in different
cities like literally i just get in my
van i just go travel to manchester for
stay in a crappy hotel for a week
and just go and
every day i'm just out there whatever
the weather talking to people getting
ignored getting love getting people
hating on me getting this getting that
just so i've already experienced like
in person every type of whether it from
from love and praise
to
complete misunderstanding to being
ignored
it's also why
i have so much like time and love and
support and gratitude for where things
are now
because yeah i'm still on my pathway but
it always blows my mind if i go to an
event especially if i'm in the states
because i'm not even from here
right my mind is blown if i'm walking
around miami and someone's like oh i
used to be like oh yeah i'm like dude
that's crazy like i'm an independent
rapper from england
i'm from another country
and i don't have any machine behind me
yeah i don't have so i don't have a team
i don't have an agent i don't have a
manager i never had loads of money put
into me or whatever and i'm like oh wow
like i'm i'm in the white house oh i'm
talking joe rogan wants to talk to me oh
i'm hanging with tucker carlson oh i'm
here with i'm here with pump like i'm
doing this i'm doing that i'm being
asked to speak it
you know uh in october i'm going to
i'm going to australia i've been invited
to speak at some big events in australia
i'm like whoa and i'm going there and
people are like yeah i can't wait for
you to come
and i'm like yo that's wild it's on the
other side of the world yeah
i'm like that's nuts like yeah i mean
you take off on monday land on wednesday
that's how far away it is
and i'm just like man so i i just feel
such an extreme gratitude for every
person i mean i i did an event um i did
a bunch of events last month i spoke at
um
the young americans for liberty
um
national student conference the young
americas foundation national
conservative student conference uh
freedom fest in las vegas and so on
and in all these events
lord knows how many
selfies i took and you know just talking
to everyone who wanted
and even sometimes with the organizers
because they always want to you know as
a speaker they always want to make sure
that you're like okay and people aren't
bothering you and i'm like it's fine
it's fine they're like yo like you don't
have to take all these and i'm like i
will take every photo
everyone wants like
i worked my butt off for this to have
like the fact that these people even
know who i am
let alone love what i'm doing and have
taken some inspiration but if it means
i'm standing here cheesing for two hours
as long as i don't have like something
else to rush off to
i will do it you you know i do meet ups
in different cities like i'll go i'll
just hang with people and i would like
to do that as long as it is
physically
possible to do no matter how big or
famous or whatever
i become in the future to me it's always
from the beginning it's always been
about people it's always been about
wanting to helping to help motivate
inspire people in different ways i don't
view myself as like oh
this is another thing that would that
change in how celebrity works now
right because before it was kind of like
you're cultivated to be a celebrity and
then you're put in this place where
you're
that's why there's so many of them are
out of touch right so they've kind of
been on this weird pedestal these stars
who could tweet and be like i'm gonna be
at the you know whatever location and no
one shows up and if you tweet and you're
like i'll be here a thousand people show
up it's like who who's famous but but
they wouldn't even do that because they
they
spinning so yeah so many of them they're
viewed in this different echelon almost
like you're not really a human
and i think what's really cool about the
kind of thing that we do and how we've
grown with organically with our social
media and everything is
um number one
you've been on that whole journey so you
keep a level of yeah we're both
confident people
but you're humble
you're humble i'm not like here like oh
i'm i'm this super celebrity guy and
y'all are below me or something it's
like no like i'm me because like because
of you you guys support me
and so that's why
i'm even able to to do this stuff
um and it's just i think it's way more
relatable it's way more real it allows
you to be authentic and it also means
that the people who know you
generally yeah of course we have our
haters or whatever but the people who
know you
they don't just know you because
you're on tv all the time
or oh you're just that famous actor or
whatever they know you because they like
what you do of course
and that is
that's awesome
but it also is um uh
is real impact i think a lot about like
um
the world there's a lot of people who
say i i do x
and you're like cool what like what what
is the impact of it and sometimes they
just don't know right they just they
don't get it but then there's a lot of
people who are like uh
um
we reach x number of people and you're
like cool but uh are they paying
attention
right
and um uh mr b's manager uh reed uh he
did a uh interview with um colin and
samir i know you've seen these guys they
they do uh interviews with uh people
like the youtube ecosystem okay
and uh uh i was listening to it someone
sent it to me and
he said something that was just
fascinating he goes if you watch three
videos of somebody on tiktok
you probably don't even know who they
are
what their name is whatever if you watch
three youtube videos of somebody you
definitely know what their name is 100
right and it's just a difference of the
audience relationship with the the
personal stuff
but then you move into longer stuff if
somebody is still listening to this
right now
they've been listening there for you
know two hours and 20 minutes or
whatever right
like damn they they definitely know what
your name is right um and then you move
it into the physical world and then you
get even to like uh uh schulten is uh
special he's got a joke he's like man
i'm judging all presidents now whether
they can move merchants here
right if you can move merchandise yeah
people like you right so like you kind
of like there's all these like stages to
it but what you realize is it comes back
to like
why do anybody care mm-hmm
it's because there's somebody you
there's some impact that happened right
there's some like real connection to it
so i even think for myself like there's
certain people who if uh if they came to
miami
[ __ ]
other people show up and i'd be like you
know what i would pay money to go there
sit and for two hours right uh uh
consume everything that they're saying
all this stuff because i i find it
fascinating or it has some impact or
whatever that's true of every single
person in the world
the difference though is the
authenticity this gets to the whole like
movie star versus people on the internet
nobody thinks that the movie star is
authentic
except for
you see some of the movie stars not
using social media to become authentic
like that's pretty much it right and
this is also how you can now
what's also funny with is you can also
tell who's an [ __ ] now
right i'm sure there are celebrities out
there who
maybe you had a certain view on and then
actually you see how they are on social
media how they talk to other people and
how they treat people i'm like man this
guy's this guy's not cool yeah [ __ ]
loser you know
and and i think i think that's dope um
some people might think
some people don't like the sort of loss
of the mystique or they don't like the
fact that oh you know they learned that
their favorite author or actor is
actually not very nice um but to me it's
cool i think that the truth is whether
or not you like the truth the truth is
good to
have out there
and um i see you eyeing up that book
this book this last thing i want to talk
about the candy calamity
which
there's a children's book yeah that you
wrote
and you published with brave books
and
it's got
amazing graphics all this stuff in it
why did you write a children's book
because it fits into a lot of what we
talked about today it does it does so i
have a simple heuristic to decide
whether or not i want to
do something and it's because i'm very
clear on my mission and i have been for
over 15 years and my mission in life is
to positively impact inspire and
motivate as many people as possible
through my words and my talents
i thought i was going to do that
primarily just through music and as time
has evolved lots of additional things
have been added to that so
if i think something is going to move
the needle on that i typically say yes
to it if i don't i typically say no
so brave books reached out to me last
year um
and they were like man we've been
following you for a while
all of our staff love what you do and
we're always sharing your tweets and
sharing clips of your videos and stuff
so we'd love to we'd love to do a
children's book with you um and i'd i'd
heard of them already because i know a
couple people who'd done books with them
and i was like yeah let's do it
let's do it
clearly passes that test i mean
children are not a demographic that i've
primarily
targeted
um
teenagers with my music you know lots of
teenagers who bought my music and stuff
but that sort of younger age group and i
was like oh cool and then
they were like have a think about what
sort of topics they typically do more
books that are more
sociopolitical
in in terms of the overall message it's
not on the nose because it's still
children's books but i was like you know
what i want to do one that's totally
apolitical um has no
slant to it in any way and just has a
positive and inspiring message 2019 i'd
written my book for um adults called
strong advice the zoopy's guide to
fitness for everybody that's you know
sold over 10 000 copies independently
helped a lot of people to lose weight
and get in shape and i was like
man there aren't that many children's
books talking about health and fitness
and why why why is it important you know
parents will tell their kids
eat healthy you know go out and exercise
what
they won't normally tell them why
and i was like okay let me have a story
which is fun and it's an adventure and
it's beautifully illustrated and i made
it all rhyme um but it's about the
importance of health nutrition exercise
and self-control so in the story of the
in the book it's about not going um
avoiding the extremes right not to be a
complete lazy slob and to sit there and
eat candy all day but also don't
exercise and forget to eat don't
exercise to the point that you're
forgetting to eat and you're exhausting
yourself and you're and you're passing
out that there's a healthy balance so
that's the message i wanted to convey in
the book and um
it was also just fun you know i also say
yes to things that
excite me as soon as i heard i was like
yo actually
a children's book wasn't on my radar but
it is right now and that would be cool
and that'll be fun and that'll help more
people and um it's done so and it's
doing that what has been the response
from like parents and stuff
yeah so really really positive i i've
had some really nice uh videos and
photos which are always fun to get like
just people send you a dm and it's like
their child holding their child holding
the book or like them reading i'm like
man that's
that's so beautiful um
so i'm not a parent yet i do have nine
nieces and nephews so i that's basically
yeah so when i was actually writing it i
was running it by them they ranged
between like
three and 16.
so
so i was when it was still just digital
before i got printed i was showing them
you know have a look at it and even just
putting on an ipad and seeing how
captivated they are and you know see can
can you read along with the rhymes and
so on
so i kind of was able to field test it a
little bit on them yeah yeah you're
going on a little sort of this book was
a b tested by a group of nine kids
where can people go to get the book you
can get the book at candycalamity.com
okay um brave books which is at
bravebooks.com they also do a
subscription so they release a new book
every month so if someone wants to get
their monthly book you can get the
subscription targeted for kids yeah
they're all they're all children's books
um but yeah candy calamity.com
that can grab it right there uh i just
love also by the way i don't know if
people are gonna be able to see if
they're watching on the video but the
the look of the candy right on the front
i'm like yeah i've been yeah
before
yeah and if you're a zoobee fan it's got
it's got a couple uh it's got a couple
little references in there that people
might understand like okay dude
[Laughter]
you you have been able to capitalize on
a number of different ridiculous uh
events from the uh the dead lifting to
the okay dude okay dude
did you ever get any blow back for the
the shirts and all that no no you just
laughed
i made five figures from it but um yeah
okay from the merch
but yeah no uh no blob i mean
i'll be honest man people always ask me
about blowback and hate and criticism
and nasty stuff and yeah there's some of
it but honestly it's it's
like maybe two percent
and it's and it's only online yes it's
only online in the real world everything
is cool everything's blessed people are
ultra nice i've had people come up to me
in the stream but yo pop what's up yeah
maybe i speak to whatever dm me on
twitter so that i uh have your
information or whatever
and i will go look
and in the [ __ ] dm
will be poppy you're an idiot like oh
really
i'm like
and you know it's like two years before
yeah i'm like
don't dm me if that's what you do before
like what and i just been like are you
good
and they're like yeah sorry man you know
i just had a bad day that day whatever
like and i'm cool dude that happens all
the time yeah i i i tell people this
especially people who want to grow on
social media
there are right now there are millions
of people scrolling through their
twitter facebook and instagram feeds
looking for something to get upset about
yes they're having a bad day they're
already angry and you might just be the
person that day
who comes across their feet who's saying
something they don't like and it's
don't take it personally right sometimes
people are just in a nasty mood and
you're the person who's in their
crosshairs that day and they lash out at
you also some people just have weird
ways of trying to get attention
so they might think by saying by calling
you an idiot that's the best way to get
your attention um in some ways it kind
of is because we react more to negatives
than
you'll certainly get noticed
but i'm probably not going to do you any
favors
after you've called me an idiot so i
it's not the approach i recommend but
and some of it's probably just bots i
just look i always i'm sorry you feel
that way yeah i'll try to do better next
time
[Laughter]
right and they're like
it's kind of hard right or like i
remember one time somebody uh i think it
was an email yeah i appreciate you
emailed me and he was the biggest
[ __ ] [ __ ] but whatever and i just
want
and just being like well if i was the
smartest guy in the room i'd be in the
wrong room
right and then they're kind of like
disarming people
but yeah just like how do you react to
somebody sometimes sometimes i've had
people like apologize like someone comes
at me like super harsh
and then i won't respond in kind and
i'll be kind of like uh you know like i
hope you hope you still have a good day
or whatever and they're like and then
you know they'll message a couple sorry
man that was kind of announced
yeah yeah yeah that's cool no problem
just don't be an [ __ ] on the internet
exactly exactly all right where can we
send people find you on twitter too just
yeah sure epic at zubimusic yeah on all
social media at zubi music and what's
the website teamzubi.com teamzooby.com
and by the time this podcast comes out
the new version should have been
launched i'm doing a whole new merch
relaunch i've shifted my whole
merchandise operation to the usa got
brand new stuff yeah so
it's gonna the merch is gonna be taken
over in the next year all right so
teamzubi.com candy calamity.com that's
right and then zoobee music on all
social media that's it i uh
you are welcome here whenever you want
my friend i enjoy talking to you every
single time so thanks so much appreciate
appreciate it bro god bless